hey
you guys it's wednesday it's party time
he's back there attacking us she's
playing attacking the robot
that's what that noise is
i forgot it was in here the other one
broke and then tom fixed it but i think
it's broken she broke it again she lays
on him it breaks the
she's not that heavy yeah it's like
you'd think she was like fat or
something she's not fat she only weighs
like 10 pounds that's enough to break
that though it's made out of plastic i
guess so
so what's everybody doing let's see
who's in here
yeah okay dj's in here zach's in here
i didn't put any music in the background
because the last two times i put music
in the background
even though it said it was safe for
copyright
copies right copyright not a strike but
it was just like a warning and it was
probably copyrighted that [ __ ] because
he knew
he knew you get charged for it yeah
maybe i don't know yeah
so i was just like [ __ ] we can't hear
the [ __ ] anyway so it's like you know
the way this
like program works i'd like to put
something back there at least but
well i don't know i'll have to find some
[ __ ] rain
sounds or something yeah maybe we maybe
we can just record some rain sounds
yeah and then we won't get i'll just go
outside when it rains
and i'll just record it and then i can
put it in the background you know oh no
i have a better idea i'll record you
just like humming
yeah in the background just like just
make a make a song out of that
and then i'll just put that in the back
put a beat to it yeah there you go
and then i'll just be like yeah yeah
come at me copyright [ __ ]
right i made that [ __ ]
so uh we gotta talk about that movie
right there
we gotta talk about lots of things yeah
um
uh somebody asked uh sabrina asked if
you were feeling better today
yeah i'm feeling a little bit better i'm
not feeling like on top of
on top of my game but i'm okay yeah you
seem to sleep well again
last night you didn't wake up coughing
no i'm not coughing i just uh
got like an infection in my nose you
know my sense of smell is [ __ ] up
nothing really tastes right you know
yeah he hasn't really
eaten hardly anything they'll last like
two or three days because everything
tastes like ass
yeah just [ __ ] bland [ __ ] like leek
soup
well leek soup is good though i had some
as well it was delicious
eating that soup and had a ham and
cheese sandwich that was it
that's anything spicy it just doesn't
taste right
well bacon didn't taste right and you
know if bacon doesn't taste right then
[ __ ] you might not even eat that's
what i mean yeah
like bacon yeah well i might as well
just die
yeah i can't even taste bacon guys i'll
give up on that [ __ ]
so i don't know i don't have any idea
how long this show is gonna be tonight
but uh you can do it my way through it
you can do it
you'll be in a better mood when you get
kind of like
you know a little bit into the [ __ ]
yeah we'll see pookie's out there
playing in the box i just got one of my
new games
she's been jumping back and forth for
the box and like it had all she's like a
box with noisy paper in it
she made it yeah this just came it's not
for sale yet because
um i literally just got it like 10
minutes ago like this is a proof copy
but yeah this one is a board game too
and this is called gorgonz lair
[Music]
obviously back off the camera so like
greek mythology based yeah
yeah pretty rad show in the back you get
to like fight little monsters and
whatnot
yeah back off of the camera i know i'm
trying to
okay get everybody sick and see the
little details and [ __ ] yeah it looks
pretty good you can play a little
little different colored perseus as
perseus persei
i'm assuming and uh you have to go and
fight like all these little greek
monsters on the back here
or on the board here it's a big board
and then you have little cards that you
know
they're called gods and monsters and you
uh you either get like
cool [ __ ] like from zeus or like winged
sandals and whatnot or you get [ __ ] on
by the gods you know like while you're
fighting and stuff but yeah
super fun but yeah i'm gonna put that up
for sale later on
but uh yeah i just got it today so that
was like pretty quick
i only have a few games left that uh
that i haven't proofed yet
you know so i'm kind of like having fun
with that i still gotta finish that
halloween one goddammit
like i said it's almost done it's just
the board
has about like 15 percent more and then
i just have to make the box and then
i'll be finished
can you guys hear us just wondering if
you guys can hear it
because you're actually not uh you're
speaking real low i don't know if they
can hear us
it's fine is it fine all right i can
barely hear you i'm sitting over here
but you know maybe my ears
that's all right no one cares what i'm
saying anyway
maybe it's just because of my cold or
something but
dj maniac says you make games and books
i make custom action figures i just have
to figure out how to monetize my
operation
yeah i wonder is there anything like
that
that you can i mean there has to be
something like there has to be some kind
of company that you can outsource like
like a 3d printing company or something
like that like is that you can make like
the pieces
but it i seemed like it would be a lot
more complicated because like even
making the board games because i use
game crafter i don't think that's the
only one
out there but i've been using that one
for years and years
and they're like they're good like they
have like zillions of different
components and then they have like a
whole bunch of stuff you can pick
like um little pre-made pieces and [ __ ]
like you know little dungeons and
dragons like little metal figures
and [ __ ] like that all different colored
dice all different
[ __ ] you can pick and um and then they
have like a line
of stuff that you can customize also
so it's pretty cool it's like i you know
i really enjoy designing those like i
said because i think it
it kind of like puts together my
love of writing like coming up with a
story and also
graphic design and making a bunch of
components that are all like
thematically linked i'm really into that
for some reason
yeah making action figures that's a uh
that's a dying genre
though now i mean [ __ ] you know my
friend made all those
action figures behind me all those
japanese action figures
and um the toy
toys don't sell not to kids kids don't
want toys
kids i don't think anybody's they're
they don't grow up with those anymore
everything's all
everything's all electronics i always
figured when people say they make action
figures i just thought they made them
for collectors
yeah it's ruined on kids it's always
it's all adult collectors now and the
[ __ ] is looking super expensive
and it's not retail because the retail
market's [ __ ] trash
so it's all you know um
direct market some of the shit's [ __ ]
custom like you know the
they they had some professional [ __ ]
toy makers made that
make the whole ship from uh the
mandalorian and you had to
spend a certain amount of money to get
it i think it was 300 ahead
yeah and then once they got a certain
amount then they put them into
production
they made them what was the name of that
thing the something blade
was the name of his ship do you remember
the razor crest razor crest that's what
it was
yeah they made that razor crest it's
[ __ ] it looked awesome
i don't know if it's in production yet
but
well honestly i think the way to go is
more niche marketing i mean i've been
saying that for you like years and years
you just have to find your audience yeah
and make
you know you i feel like mass producing
stuff like that is not the way to go
nope like it's better to make looks dj
maniac just said his pieces are one of a
kind and unique see i think that's like
as long as you can find your right
audience and find like some way of
producing it that's not going to like
put you in the poor house
i think that's kind of the way to do it
because i think people are more
you know even nowadays when people have
less money i feel like people want
things that are like
individual to them you know what i mean
or like you know they want something
that other people don't have or there's
not that many of them
they don't just want the same old [ __ ]
everyone else has got you know what i
mean
so i just think that's kind of like
that's what i figure that's why i do
with my games and [ __ ] like that it's
like you know they're expensive but
i don't know i have i have fun doing it
and i figure if
if people like them then that's cool you
know
i'm not worried about it it's just
something i do on the side every now and
then
um yeah what let's talk about that movie
we saw
yeah he's just like he's usually he's
just he's in a cranky mood
come on here there you go yeah
we talked about this a little bit
yesterday yeah i forgot who sent this to
me i thought it was
thought it was hernandez but it was
somebody else sent this to me
it's a movie it's got uh it's got mark
wahlberg in it and [ __ ] um dwayne
johnson's in it
all right it's called pain and gain and
that movie was [ __ ] awesome
it's a uh it's a true crime flick
about florida it's taking place down in
um
miami miami and uh
the guys uh mark wahlberg he plays a uh
kind of like a muscle head
[ __ ] gym teacher not a gym teacher
what's good a trainer personally yeah
personal trainer and uh
he [ __ ] gets it in his [ __ ] head
that uh he goes to a
motivational speaker
i love that motivational speaker in this
movie like what was his name johnny woo
or something like that
it's like he had these big banners that
like all your friends are losers and
like get off oh get off your lazy
american ass i think was one of the
things that the ass said
this motivational speaker gets him all
[ __ ] amped up
super funny to become [ __ ] rich and
powerful
and of course how do you do that that
way you [ __ ] steal it you know i mean
that's
that's that's what that's what this
that's what comes to this guy's mind
so one of his clients is like this uh
was he venezuelan
colombia in colombia and he was a
colombian
colombian jewish guy who was um
in in the gym all the time he was
training him and
uh he just didn't like the guy the guy
was [ __ ] real obnoxious
kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] had all this money
so he decided he was gonna kidnap this
guy and get him to sign over all of his
[ __ ]
money to him and he recruits these other
[ __ ] muscle heads to do it
and it's a real it was a true you know
it's a real florida [ __ ] crime yeah
some of the [ __ ] was changed but
surprisingly not that much and what's
funny is that all the [ __ ] ridiculous
[ __ ] that happened in the movie actually
did happen
they said at the trial people were
[ __ ] laughing
you know how crazy these guys were and
they did it once and that wasn't enough
they had to do it a couple more times
think they did it again
they eventually got caught though yeah
and uh
it's just sucking unreal i mean they
steal millions of dollars worth of
[ __ ]
houses and money from this guy and
they're living in his house
it's just ridiculous you're going to
steal this dude's house you're going to
live in it
yeah they didn't even like trying they
didn't even like attempt to
they didn't even attempt to escape which
is what you you would think that that's
what you would do
like if you were going to do something
like this just a pro tip for any
criminals out there
um probably the best thing would to
would be to like abscond
from the country yeah that's just my
recommendation they just stayed right
there and pretended like they stayed in
the dude's house yeah pretend like they
didn't do anything wrong i mean
these dudes are [ __ ] real simple tits
but that is a [ __ ] excellent
one honestly this yeah it was like super
super funny now
like one of the best lines in the whole
i can't i'm sure i'm like you know
saying it wrong but it was like ed
harris who played like this
private investigator because i want to
get a little bit into the real case too
because that shit's [ __ ]
insane but he's playing like this
private investigator that actually like
got the police
you know to look into this and he says
at the very end like with the end of the
trial when they're saying like what all
the dudes
you know what sentences they all got and
everything he said they were convicted
of this that the other thing and he's
like in fact the only thing that they
weren't convicted of
is the one thing that they were most
guilty of being stupid dumb [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and it's like so okay so the thing about
it
so they made it into this is a dark
comedy and like i said it's directed by
michael bay
but don't let that dissuade you um
because
this was i guess i said this way do you
well
okay good movies yeah yeah i'm just
saying that a lot of people are like oh
michael bay is just gonna be like three
hours of explosions no thank you
but um you know he just has a little bit
of reputation like that
but the thing about it though is that
when he makes kind of a smaller movie
like this this one this only costs 24
million
uh which obviously is a lot more money
than i'll ever say in my entire lifetime
or the next several lifetimes
but is really really cheap for a michael
bay movie obviously
um this was like a passion project for
him i guess like the script he said the
script was sitting on my shelf for like
12 years and i wanted to do it
but i kept getting like the studio was
like hey you have to do transformers or
hey you have to do this like 300 million
bloated ass behemoth and he's just like
well [ __ ] so it kept getting pushed back
but finally finally
he uh got to do it and he was very
excited but like 2013
2013 it came out yeah i had never heard
about it and
it's weird because i live in florida and
you know i've
grown grown up here my whole life and
i don't remember i kind of vaguely
remember this case but i guess i wasn't
really paying attention
to the news at the time maybe it was in
the 90s when it happened
yeah 1995 i think it happened 94.95
somewhere around there
um so yes i just got lost in the shuffle
yeah i think i was too big i was like in
college i was like [ __ ]
you know going to gigs and [ __ ] like
that so it's like probably i wasn't even
like
i was just coming out of the army so you
know yeah and miami was
miami area was just known just being it
was like it was still kind of like the
miami vice era
back then you know i mean that wasn't
that far gone
you know uh [ __ ]
miami's wild it used to be a lot wilder
but
you know miami's [ __ ] wild you never
can tell what's gonna happen down there
matter in the making of the movie you
know these are all [ __ ]
these guys are all california guys you
know coming down here to make this movie
and they were just like real [ __ ]
shocked by
florida culture you know well and also
how hot and humid it is how hot and
humid it is
i feel you you're like they're like
everybody's carrying guns
like two guns you know yeah yeah they go
to the gun store and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
you know
yeah because that was a real gun store
that yeah well a lot of the locations
they used were relocated real locations
you know [ __ ] and they didn't really
do
miami miami's got some really [ __ ]
cool gun stores you know
[ __ ] assault rifles all the [ __ ]
walls and
you can buy all this [ __ ] cool [ __ ]
and they just they're just not really
used to seeing that in california but oh
man
florida florida's [ __ ] wide open with
all that sheila said they did the case
on 48 hours i actually watched that
earlier
today so i saw it it's on youtube
somewhere but um
it's funny because even though this
movie is hilarious
you do have to think like in the actual
case like a dude did get kidnapped and
tortured for a month
and he lost all his [ __ ] yeah and
also two people got murdered and
dismembered so
and what's funny is like you know dude
got
dude got tortured and got all of his
[ __ ] [ __ ] stolen and he goes to the
cops
the cops didn't believe him we're like
get out of here well because it's co i
mean [ __ ] out here
i'm not defending it i'm
but it did sound like an implausible
yeah they're like no it didn't happen
because it is an implausible story
they're leaving
my house basically i mean i don't you
know i don't know exactly what happened
like when he came back because he was in
a coma for a while i think
yeah um and when he came out of it and
he was like all [ __ ] beat up i mean
he was like on the [ __ ] verge of
death and we didn't
get into like but he was colombian too
so they were like yeah right
well yeah they thought it was like a
drug dealer right which he wasn't
you know what i mean and the thing about
it though and i'll get into this a
minute too was he was involved in some
illegal activity but
um it was like it was it was like white
collar it was like medicare fraud or
some [ __ ] like that
yeah um but it wasn't like drug related
but um so i mean in the movie they show
them just kind of like
coming too and then basically the first
thing that he says is i was kidnapped by
ninjas
yeah you took all my stuff which like i
said it sounds stupid and it's not but
it was true i mean the dudes were
trusting the dudes were dressed up as
ninjas when they came
and on one time one of the dudes it was
two dudes dressed up as ninjas and one
dude dressed up like a e.t
yeah i don't know i thought it was like
the thing about it is that what they did
for the movie
like i guess to make it funnier and to
make it simpler
because the actual case was a lot more
complicated and there were a lot more
people involved
like they call it the sun gym gang um
there were actually a hell of a lot more
of them than three people
there were at least seven people or at
least seven that did time
um i don't know if there were other ones
that were like on the periphery or
whatever
and the thing about the dude that they
kidnapped at first
whose real name i think was mark
schiller i want to say
yeah i think they didn't say what is
wrong and that wasn't the character's
name in the movie
some of the characters were the same but
like character names are the same but
some of the ones they changed from real
life
um so basically they
that guy i don't think that that guy
went to the gym you know what i mean um
basically he knew another guy named
joseph delgado i think
and joseph delgado was like his
was that dude's personal trainer or
personal assistant or something like
that
and joseph delgado went to that gym and
was friends with
lugo who um mark wahlberg plays in the
movie
so it was kind of like a secondhand like
hey
i know this guy like i work for this guy
i know like all the codes to his how
like how to get in his house and all
this other kind of [ __ ]
um and that's how they ended up doing it
i don't think that guy personally like
came to the gym
but like i said i can see why they did
that for the movie because that's like
much made more sense in the movie
and and like i said the the character
that the rock plays um
i think his name is doyle paul doyle or
something like that um
that dude didn't exist he was just like
an amalgamation
of some of the other people like i said
so they can make it more focused
because like i said there was like a
whole bunch of dudes and like they
weren't all involved
in every aspect of it you know what i
mean it's funny man they can't
when they cut after the kidnapping dude
they kept him in a warehouse
and [ __ ] it was a warehouse full of
[ __ ] sex toys
sex toys and [ __ ] x-rated [ __ ] that's
where they had it kept
yeah that was joseph delgado's warehouse
but i don't i don't know if it was a sex
toy warehouse
in the movie it was but in real life i
don't know it was just like a warehouse
that he had for
some business proposition or whatever it
was just funny good movie but the um
interestingly when they i don't even
know if they i don't even remember if
they did this in the movie
but when they kidnapped the guy
they made seven attempts to kidnap him
some of the attempts the first thing
they were going to do was they were all
going to dress as ninjas and they were
going to go to his house
trick-or-treating on halloween
and they were going to grab him when he
opened the door and then for some reason
that didn't come to pass
and then one night they decided they
were just going to snatch him when he
came out in the morning to get the
newspaper
like out from the front of his house so
they all put on [ __ ] military
tactical gear
and they like and they like lay down and
they were like crawling across
the [ __ ] like i said i don't even think
this is in the movie but they they were
like crawling across the
line they did that they kind of did it
they were crawling across his lawn and
then a car went by
because it's a neighborhood and there's
a street and they flipped out and they
started running the street going aboard
abort
like the investigator said he's like
what the [ __ ] it's like they're just
running they should they show something
like that
remember that they had they put on the
camouflage stuff and they [ __ ]
and they were out in front of the house
in the morning and they ran they showed
that oh okay yeah i didn't remember that
it must have been really short yeah but
yeah they were like trying to like hide
into the bushes and [ __ ] like that
yeah but it's just it was [ __ ] it's
ridiculous it was ridiculous
and you know it it's kind of sad like i
said because
they kind of you know it's a black
comedy i mean obviously like horrible
[ __ ] happens in it like i said the dude
gets kidnapped and tortured and like
also later two people get murdered and
you know cut up and everything um but
they made it so they didn't make it like
as horrible as it was in the [ __ ]
in real life because when they kidnapped
that dude he was
chained to a pipe like in a bathroom in
this warehouse
for a month i think yeah and
um they didn't feed him sometimes for
days at a time
they wouldn't let him go to the bathroom
so he just had to like you know
piss and [ __ ] on himself and they would
threaten him they were gonna i'm gonna
bring your wife in here and rape her in
front of you
and they did that kind of [ __ ] and
you know they [ __ ] set them on fire
they like electrocuted with them tasers
they did like all this other kind of
[ __ ]
but the thing about it was that this
dude was a [ __ ]
he was hardcore he was a badass it's
like give it up
i mean it took that's why it took so
long they had to keep torturing him it
took them a month because he was they
were trying to get him to sign over
all of his [ __ ] like sign over your
house in your car and all this other
kind of crap
and so it took him it took them a month
to get
him to finally do that and then they're
gonna kill him so they just
they plied him with alcohol in the movie
it was just like
you know let's pour a bunch of alcohol
down his throat in real life it was
three to five days
they just kept giving him alcohol and
kept giving and like sleeping pills and
[ __ ] like that
and they put him behind the wheel of a
car and then they crashed the car
into um like a bridge abutment or
something like that
and then they tried to set the car on
fire and the dude
climbed out yeah he still lived and
started staggering like toward him and
then they ran him over they like ran him
over into a wall
and then they tried to back over him but
then like another car came and they
flipped out and they left
yeah it was indestructible yeah and i
was just like holy crap dude like they
interviewed him on the um
on the 48 hours that i saw and i felt
really bad for him i mean like
you know it was funny they said he was
kind of unlikable um
he didn't seem all that unlikable like
in in real life but maybe they just kind
of see him like that for them
kind of unlikable but that and the cops
didn't believe him
too well cause like i said that's a
pretty crazy i thought he was a drug
dealer
and the thing about it too was that one
of the reasons that he was targeted by
the
the muscle head gang in the first place
was because
the dude that turned um lugo onto him
delgado
that other guy that came to the gym that
was like that works for him
he said yeah i think this dude's
involved in like some medicare fraud
because he owned like a medical billing
business or something like he did have a
schwatzke's deli just like in the movie
that was real but um he had been
involved in medical billing and they
thought that he was doing medicare fraud
so that was something that they could
hold against him so they thought they
could blackmail him if they needed to
and so they and so they figured well he
won't go to the cops you know what i
mean which he didn't
um for a really long time although he
said that he went to the cops a few
times and they didn't believe him
which i you know i buy that but
it was um only later after that other
couple had disappeared
the guy that was um the hungarian guy
that was owned
all the phone sex stuff that was like a
millionaire and uh his girlfriend
when they disappeared and then it was
like two different departments that
we're working on because one was working
on the kidnapping case and then one was
working on this murder case full of like
these [ __ ] bodies that they had found
like [ __ ] cut up in barrels in the
everglades
and um then they figured out that both
of them were related because
as i said this this sun gym gang they
were all
you know gym rats they were probably all
doing steroids
oh they were they weren't the brightest
bulbs
by any stretch of the imagination and it
was just like
they just did the [ __ ] dumbest [ __ ]
they were not
i mean they just didn't really they had
a plan but it was a really stupid plan
you know what i'm saying it was just
like something meathead would just make
up just
just off the top of his [ __ ] head
yeah and then it was they didn't really
think it through
yeah it was obvious they were just
making it up as they were going along as
things would happen they would just try
to make a new response to it it was just
there wasn't a grand plan that was the
great that that's really the great part
of the movie though it's just these guys
they really think they're on top of
their [ __ ] game really they just
think that they're [ __ ] jesus and
they're just
dumbasses and but it's funny though
they're there and they're likeable
they said that even in real life that
you know even while these dudes were
getting sentenced to [ __ ] death and
[ __ ]
people liked him they were laughing at
him they were
knuckleheads [ __ ] knuckleheads yeah
that's exactly what they were and that's
what like michael bay was saying
he's like one dumb criminals are always
funny which
yes that's true and um he was talking
about mark wahlberg and he's like mark
wahlberg is like the best actor
to play like a really earnest
person who thinks they're way smarter
than they are except they're an idiot
yeah and he's he's really really i mean
because you know he was in boogie nights
like dirk diggler was kind of a
character like that
very similar it's a very similar kind of
character like if you want a character
like that that's your go-to guy because
he's so
so good at playing that's funny what's
funny about it is it starts off
okay he's working in this gym around a
bunch of these just [ __ ]
i mean hotties these girls just look
[ __ ] fantastic these
fitness model type chicks all right and
he's got
a little [ __ ] fiero and he's [ __ ]
he's
looking great you know what i mean and
he's got really he's really got
everything he needs
yeah but it's not enough all right he's
living a good life
he's already a little bit of an ex-con
anyway you know yeah he had been
convicted of fraud yeah it wasn't like a
big deal he did like a year or so
you think he did some probation or some
[ __ ] yeah but um
he was actually living a a pretty good
life
but that wasn't enough for him he wanted
to [ __ ] live
like a multi-millionaire he wanted a
huge [ __ ] mansion
you know out there and [ __ ] out there
and [ __ ]
in the best [ __ ] neighborhoods in
miami you know golden beach i think
yeah you know he wanted he wanted to
[ __ ] live the [ __ ]
the high life you know and he was
willing to kill other people to get it
which yeah his whole thing but he was
trying to put like a positive spin on
all this
i'm a doer i just get things done you
know that's what was so weird about it
it's just like i just have ambitions you
know it's like all this [ __ ] is totally
normal
you know well the thing about it i feel
kidnapped this guy
and yeah eventually we'll have to kill
him but oh well you know
i feel like he had gotten to a point
where he thought
he worked really hard like you know
working out or doing
whatever it was doing and he should have
been doing much better
right and he didn't understand why
people that he
perceived as not working as hard as him
had a lot more than he had a lot more
than he did and he thought that he
deserved to have that too
he says a lot of the [ __ ] character
in the movie is great because he says a
lot of [ __ ] little sayings they have
to do with fitness
and he tries to get that to [ __ ] fit
in just with
the his whole plan in life you know
being that
this [ __ ] all work out because he
believes in fitness just crazy [ __ ] like
that
you know it is just yeah because he
goodness doesn't have anything to do
with cause he's an idiot but like i said
i feel like like i get i think that
that's why the movie works is because
even though everything these people did
was reprehensible
yeah i mean you could almost understand
how
somebody could get to that point you're
like look i've spent all this time like
working on my body because it is very
difficult and
you know and yeah he was a manager at
this gym and everything but
he just felt like he was he would see
these clients come into the gym
because he was a personal trainer and
they had all this money they had all
this money and
i guess he felt like they didn't deserve
it i think
yeah i think his take on it was is like
this is is like
i'm a doer i believe in [ __ ] fitness
and
long life and longevity so therefore i
should have all this [ __ ] money
you know what i mean i should be a
winner just all around i shouldn't be a
millionaire
yeah these other people have millions of
dollars and don't care about themselves
or their bodies and they don't even try
hard
you know so why do they have that yeah
yeah that's how he was
how did they get that you know and he
comes out and says you know to that dude
he says i'm taking this from you because
i don't want you to have it
yeah basically you're going to give all
your money to me because i don't
i don't care just as long as you don't
have it yeah you know
so that was kind of the thinking
but you know it's what's and that guy
was responding to him like it uh he told
him he's like
he's like if you'd gone to college
you wouldn't sit around worried about
your pectoral muscles
which that guy was an [ __ ] too but it
was just two different kinds of [ __ ]
[ __ ] judging each other it was
[ __ ] funny
guys that make a lot of money make a lot
of money because they have certain
behavior patterns that allow them to
make a lot of money and you have to have
money to start off with
that that helps usually although i will
uh i will say that the guy that he
killed
uh you know him and the girlfriend yeah
that was totally different guys that
yeah that was totally different
but that guy yeah um because what ended
up happening was that they did actually
succeed in getting all of mark
schiller's
[ __ ] they got all his money they got his
cars and actually it was his yell
he had like a yellow lamborghini was it
him or was the other guy i can't
remember
but um that was one of the reasons why
they caught him because that dude was
like driving around or whatever
but once they they blew through
all that dude's money okay like all of
mark schiller's money
they were living in his house they were
not only living in his house and
partying with like all their russian
girlfriends like stripper girlfriends
and stuff
but they were they started like a
neighborhood watch they were like
training the neighbors
telling everybody they worked for the
government telling everybody they were
cia agents
it's like it was [ __ ] ridiculous it's
like you should have just left you
probably would have got away with it
but they blew through all that dude's
money it was like three million dollars
so it was like some unbelievable amount
and then they said okay well all that
money's gone so we got to do another one
so then they targeted this other guy
now this guy though he had come to the
u.s
from hungary with ten dollars yeah
and he started a phone sex empire that
ended up
being like millions and millions because
this was in the 90s like all these kind
of like you could do that 976 numbers
and all that kind of stuff so he got in
on the ground floor that kind of [ __ ]
and he made [ __ ] tons of money yeah and
um
and he was only in his 30s he was i
think he was only like 32 something like
that his girlfriend was 24
something like that and um dude that
actually [ __ ] pulled himself
up from the bootstraps yeah which like i
said you know i don't know what else was
going on maybe he had family that helped
maybe he had like other
miami there's always drugs involved well
that too and it's like i'm sure there's
always that because it the thing about
it i think that
a lot of the thing about you know people
oh i only had five dollars in my pocket
and then like now i'm a
multi-millionaire
it's like i feel like that's a infinite
infinite tesla infinitesimally small
percentage of
because you need resources you need some
you need to know i mean at least if you
have information you have to have
information you have to at least
know somebody that knows somebody how to
make money because it's like how the
[ __ ] are you just going to be like some
homeless bomb and then all of a sudden
i'm a multi-millionaire like you can
work your way up it just doesn't happen
it doesn't happen that way you can give
millions of dollars to a poor person
with bad habits and they will
have [ __ ] though all that money will
be gone in a couple of years
and they'll be um very unhappy too
it [ __ ] them up you can't give a lot of
money to a poor person it [ __ ] them up
well it depends on the poor person that
you're talking in general all you gotta
do is just look at [ __ ] people that
win lotteries and stuff
usually it's gone quickly and they're
very dissatisfied when it is and [ __ ]
they didn't really enjoy it
you can um give money you can
you can take a take some of these rich
guys and take all their money away from
them
and within a year later they're a
millionaire again it's really more about
the behavior and the information that
they have and all the connections that
they have that's
connections i think is the main thing
big thing
right i mean if you don't know anybody
that knows anything about anything
if you don't know how to make money if
you don't know how you got to have the
right friends
yeah i think that's what the hell is
going on and you know the whole scene
and having money there there's a there's
a money seen
and they'll let you in and if they don't
let you in you
and you know you can give money to a guy
who has okay habits and maybe he might
be able to turn into something but it's
better to have [ __ ]
well-connected friends than anything
else that's the main thing
yeah i think that's really one of the
biggest things but um
yeah there's been a lot of stories rags
to riches stories we got
take somebody doesn't have a pot to piss
in they win a couple million bucks on
the lottery and then
they they [ __ ] catch up with them 10
years later and they're just [ __ ]
busy
because they don't have any they don't
have any context or framework in how to
like
spend that or what to do with it it
means all their friends and [ __ ] well
and the thing about it too
is that when you're poor which i should
know as a poor person
um when you have if you won like a
million dollars or two million dollars
to you it would seem infinite
yeah it goes fast because you know
you've always had to like scrape like
down to the last penny and everything
like that so now suddenly it just seems
like you have
infinite money yes they do [ __ ] like
start buying boats and cars and
giving [ __ ] to [ __ ] they probably don't
even want then they buy a house and then
the [ __ ] and then the house
bad investments and stuff and the next
thing you know they can't pay for it all
then
it's all gets repossessed they don't
really have anything left
well that's the thing these guys they
actually successfully
i mean i don't know if i want to use
that word because they tortured a dude
like [ __ ] to get him to sign all his
[ __ ] away to them
like all his savings in his car and his
house and everything they got all his
[ __ ]
all his cash all his assets his house
all of that
and they proceeded to blow it all
in i think it was only a few months
maybe maybe it was a year or two but
they blew it all on drugs strippers
parties they blew it all on that and
then they ended up having to
having to well they felt like they had
to kill somebody else they like later to
do it
and the the shitty thing about it is
that had the police the miami dade
police actually believed
mark schiller's story when he woke up
from his coma because they thought
oh it was just a drunk driving accident
so like when he wakes up and says
hey i was kid kidnapped by ninjas and
they took all my [ __ ] um
you know the cops are like yeah okay
tell us another one
and but if the if the police had
listened to him
then those other people would still be
alive um
but that wasn't how it happened it
actually ended up having to be like i
said there was a
there was a private investigator ed
dubois i think his name was ed harris
played him in the movie
and um he actually
uh believed mark schiller's case
so he actually went to the cops and was
kind of like hey
you need to like look into this i
believe him and and that was when they
started looking into the connection
between like the kidnapping and the
other thing
because as i said as dumb as the
meathead dudes were
um they actually did
at least succeed in making the police
believe
that this guy had just drunkenly slammed
his
car into a point i think i think it was
more because the cops didn't think
[ __ ] offenders would be that [ __ ]
stupid
you know what i mean you think they
would know better by now though live in
another man's house
there's all his [ __ ] there's volumes of
books about stupid quotes like world's
dumbest criminals it was a whole tv
series there was a whole series of books
dwayne johnson did a great job in this
fight
the rock plays this guy who's kind of
like the main enforcer for the whole
[ __ ] gang
and he's like he's a christian and he's
looking
he's he's he's recovering alcoholic yeah
yeah
and uh he's just a very likable guy
in the movie and they're trying to get
him to do all the [ __ ] beating up
dudes and
trying to get all the things he's a coke
fiend and he [ __ ] a spot
he gets hooked up with the russian
stripper and the next thing you know he
starts sliding into cocaine instead of
drinking and then uh
all kinds of [ __ ] funny [ __ ] starts
happening
he falls apart and then he uh
it's just just got to see it man and he
he's
he's he's tries to be a good guy he is a
good guy he's just that he's he's very
weak
you know i mean he's easy to uh
manipulate into doing all this stupid
[ __ ] did it
yeah i think that's kind of what they
said about a lot of questions you know
yeah because like i said i'm not sure
because his character
as i said is kind of an amalgamation of
several different people that were in
the gang
it's just the character that he plays
yeah but um
they did say that in real life uh lugo
the um daniel lugo i think his name was
uh the mark wahlberg character
that he was as stupid as he was um he
was actually like
i guess he was like the smartest one in
his group of friends which
wasn't all that smart but it was like
smart enough to be able to just like
tell them all what to do yeah because
they said that that other
that other guy um what was his name
adorable or whatever his name was
his kind of second-hand dude black guy
yeah although in real life i think he
was
puerto rican or yeah i can't remember i
can't remember what was his what
was the name of the character that what
was the name of the actor that played
that character
mackie mackey yeah yeah alex andy mackey
alex
i thought it should say on the back you
got your glasses right
yeah yeah also i liked the little
subplot
that they added with rebel wilson
anthony anthony
i knew it started with an a yeah um does
a great job in it too
you know because his whole thing was
that he was like
i don't know about real life but anthony
mackie he plays the character
all right is he he's a young black guy
in the movie he's a young black guy in
reality he's he's probably like puerto
rican right i think
or something like i couldn't really tell
because i'm looking at that kind of
movie he kind of the picture was shitty
he kind of reminds me of a character
that seemed like a young eddie murphy
would play
and he kind of doesn't [ __ ] feel that
he's good enough so he's on roids to try
to get bigger as
big as he [ __ ] possibly can and it's
just a [ __ ]
his character has got a good good story
arc it's funny
he uh jacked on roy
come on man come on you know just real
[ __ ] super aggressive
um funny
he ends up uh he's got this [ __ ]
fetish for [ __ ] heavy white girls
which he finds [ __ ] heavy white guys
yeah rebel wilson is played by robert
wilson
[ __ ] robert wilson's [ __ ] singing
songs to him about his black beauty
and [ __ ] like that was that even in the
movie i think was it that was like in
the
in the in the outtakes but i think it
was just i like her she's fine i think
it was just in the outtakes
at her at her uh at their wedding she's
[ __ ] singing to him about it
that he is her black beauty and [ __ ]
going on and she's just she's into these
[ __ ] black guys and
it's [ __ ] funny you know what i mean
it and at the end of the movie when he
gets [ __ ] busted and he's in [ __ ]
prison or when he's in when he's in
trial
she [ __ ] testifies against him and
uses that as an opportunity to tell
everyone that he's got a little dick
that's crooked
okay that [ __ ] you know just she
just goes on and on and
he's sitting there just melting in his
[ __ ] mouth well because that's how i
don't know
about real life but that's how in the
movie that's how
he met her because he because of the
steroids like he couldn't he could get
it up yeah he was impotent
he had to go to the clinic he had to go
to the penis clinic yeah and she was
like the nurse that was like looking
after him
she oh michael was the one see michael
sent it to you
who did mike mikey see i thought it was
i said if it wasn't louis it was
probably michael because
yeah because you two guys send us movies
yeah thanks for sending you sent me this
one you sent me uh
uh death wish death wish yeah we just
watched that it was like
you're right man this move this oh my
god we were dying
we were dying it was so [ __ ] funny i
was [ __ ] rolling i love that and i
didn't even like remember that case
because it was so long ago it's true
crime is florida it's got [ __ ]
muscle heads in it it's got [ __ ]
miami [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
it's it's perfect i love that movie it's
[ __ ] hilarious
all right you know yeah it's good it's
good and it's it's just a very good
movie
it's like i felt i don't know like i was
watching the 48 hours earlier and i felt
a little bit bad
because i was just kind of like the poor
guy um
you know the first guy that got
kidnapped they were like interviewing
him on there and he seemed like a lovely
man and i was just kind of like
man i feel because he because he was
like yeah they made a movie about it and
he's like
it's a comedy that's kind of unfortunate
you know what i mean because he got
tortured and everything but it's like
still though i mean the movie is like
super i'm not gonna put it away i'm
gonna watch it again
yeah i actually would have went so we
watched all the extras too yeah we just
we watched the movie and then we just
like put all the extras on and the
extras it turns out that all the cops
were played by real miami
cops well i guess michael bay that's i'm
not a big like michael bay connoisseur
he likes to have real cops
but well he likes to have real
everything like in his movies and i
guess like he
usually has the budget to like pull that
off it's like hey can we get like the
[ __ ] army and [ __ ] on this and
they're like uh
sure mr bae whatever you want but um and
also
something that they said too the [ __ ]
that was done i think the house that
belonged to the couple that he killed
in the movie yeah that was michael bay's
house
in my in miami um because i'm pretty
sure he's like well this was a 24
million dollar
movie which like i said where somebody
give me 24 million dollars
like it was nothing at michael bay's
like yeah it's such a small budget movie
and i'm like
yeah throw me some of that [ __ ] bread
dude but um
we'll see how we'll see how nothing it
is but um
he was like trying to save money so a
lot of the [ __ ] that they filmed
they filmed it because michael bay i
guess lives in miami um i don't know if
he lives there full-time but he's got a
big house there
and uh so they all know him and so they
let him film like in the streets they
got the [ __ ] cops the [ __ ]
national guard
involved um he shot all that [ __ ]
in his house the funniest thing to me
this like i don't know why this made me
laugh so hard but um
when all the crew was like coming to his
house he's like oh it was so awesome
like when we got to shoot my house
because i could just
the crew would get there at 7 30 in the
morning and i'd just like come down to
my robe with my coffee
or maybe from my room or whatever like
to and i'm like yeah it must be nice
but he had like all these signs
everywhere keep off the grass keep on
like he don't want the crew like walking
out his [ __ ] grass
and it just like made me laugh that he
put these [ __ ] ugly signs all over
his yard because he was worried about
all the people trampling over his
[ __ ] grass
and i'm like dude it's florida in summer
your grass is gonna die
anyway it's gonna turn [ __ ] brown
unless they put unless he i mean he's
got zillions of dollars so i'm sure they
have some kind of magical [ __ ] that
keeps the grass looking good all year
round
yeah michael you you called it man yeah
i like that [ __ ] movie that that's
one of my favorite movies that's
that's going up there with uh [ __ ] what
else
that's up there with um
uh the great lebowski big lebowski big
lebowski
yeah that's up there with uh um [ __ ]
the karate one the [ __ ] artist out
the fans
that's up there with uh
yeah that's about it's about uh yeah
it's it's good movie
i mean i'm not drunk i'm not feeling
well i'm sick i'm drunk
he's trying to like drink away though
yeah i'm trying to drink away the rona
yeah it's not growing she's always
trying
it might be it's just [ __ ] cold
it's just it's right here man my nose
smells like [ __ ] like a burning fire
and plastic but i liked it just because
i
did it did encapsulate the insanity that
is [ __ ] florida
yeah like i said this is one of the most
florida other other than that dude that
ate that other dude's face
that's florida too i think i
think this might be the most florida
thing ever yeah
i had me right there i'm like going yeah
yeah that's happening
yeah that's it yep and you know i'm not
a florida
native but i'm a florida resident i am
i'm gonna
she's she is she's um but i'm an adopted
[ __ ] floridian
i love florida i probably i'm gonna stay
probably stay in florida the rest of my
life
um unless it gets [ __ ] up but florida
is i've been to a lot of different
states and florida's kind of like
it's kind of like across there there are
some
states in the united states that are
kind of like their own countries
like louisiana is like its own country
texas is like its own country well big
time i think that's probably the prime
example right right there
[ __ ] mississippi's like its own
country florida is definitely like its
own country
very weird thing about florida though um
in that regard
is that we're in a way we're kind of
like california because every
almost everybody reminded me of here
california when i was a kid almost
everybody here is a transplant they're
from somewhere else
so i think what ends up happening is
that you get
the best and the worst from everywhere
else
i mean you get so many people coming
down here just because
it's warm like the weather's nice well i
don't know it's not
nice it's weather's [ __ ] terrible
it's awful [ __ ] hot and humid
but it some people like it
i do not you know having done time in
brazil and [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's
it's like that it's it's brazil is
actually not quite as
hot but it's like a south or a central
american country it just has that
that vibe it's like satan's [ __ ] it
was always part
of what was part of [ __ ] the spanish
empire
when spain owned it it was under the
control of seminole mercenaries and
stuff and
ended up switching side becoming
american deer becoming the
part of the united states under the
[ __ ] under the pressure of
general jackson you know android andrew
jackson caused it to flip
it is an american state but it does not
yield to a lot of american [ __ ] it
does not have american sensibilities
it's like central america
it does kind of have that vibe to it's
very schizo like
like i said i was born here and as i
said that's very unusual i think when i
was in high school
um you know i went to seabreeze high
school in daytona beach
um and i was the only as far as i can
remember i was the only person
in my graduating class at least that i
knew of
that was born here yeah now um no my
best friend was born in gainesville but
she
other than that she was the only other
person that i knew it's weird though
it's like
central america and mississippi had a
collision because the panhandle is just
like mississippi that's like alabama
it's like alabama mississippi panhandle
same [ __ ]
but it it blends it gets along very well
it gets along very well i mean the
the weird thing about florida is that
you have
kind of like that when i say that it's
kind of schizo
it kind of has a little bit of
everything you have
a lot of redneck you have like some big
kind of cosmopolitan cities sort of like
miami the tampa area
to an extent orlando's not like anything
you know
in like really really big cities but if
it's new
yeah because it's newer um then you have
like really really rural [ __ ] you have
like [ __ ] swamp
yeah um you have like [ __ ] just all
kind of
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] like that you have
and you have like all these on you can
have this or
in orlando you have these on enclaves of
like
different um immigrants like i said i
like orlando we have little
india a lot of indians and a lot of
brits
yeah which is weird a lot of vietnamese
a lot of so there's like these just
little enclaves of like all these
different immigrants like living like
all the way across the island
right here is like half indian from
india
yeah they love it here all right um it's
weird though too
a lot of our club friends are from new
york like you know i mean they're sick
in new york they move here
well i think that's gone back to [ __ ]
when i was a little kid like a lot of
new yorkers would move down
especially when they were retired
because they were like sick of the cold
or whatever
so they would move down here because
it's like hot all year round pretty much
and then sometimes you run across new
yorkers that don't belong here too you
know i mean like new yorkers that
liked new york but maybe were forced out
for some reason i don't know
and they just look appalled by what's
happening you know what i mean i've seen
that too
i mean it's not i wouldn't call this
like [ __ ] it's not like
south america or central america level
crazy but it is
it does have a little bit of that vibe
to it yeah but
i will say that it depends on where you
go also
because what neighborhoods well and no
it depends on what
part of florida you go to i mean you go
to
like if you go like i grew up on the
east coast like daytona
is super redneck you have it and it's
like it's
either it's kind of a combo like i've
been there in a while but um
you know cups my family still lives
there it's like it's like halfway
between redneck because you have like
the nascar track is there there's like
you know and all that
other kind of [ __ ] and then you have
like um
you know this whole spring break like
beach calls like you know
college douche bag kind of culture so
you have that
kind of [ __ ] going on um and that's
pretty much
it so you know what i mean so there
there's that dynamic there
then it's weird because then you go like
50 miles up the coast
and you have saint augustine which is
just
which is america's oldest city if you
didn't know uh was founded by the
spanish back in the 1500s
and um that's kind of like a big tourist
mecca but the people that live there
because it's not real big like as you
know
in regards to residents you know what i
mean because their main
thing is tourism but the people that
live there like really
not so much anymore i guess but they
used to be like super super insular
you know what i mean so that's there's
that whole thing going on
then you got like the space coast um you
know kind of melbourne
you know cape canaveral sort of area and
then
south florida which is you know largely
cuban you have like a massive massive
like miami
you have like a whole bunch of old
people like i said because a lot of
people retire there
there's like a huge huge gay culture
there's uh
like i said a lot of cubans some
haitians so there's all that kind of
stuff the interesting thing about it is
the west coast
tampa because i lived there for a little
while too that also has a
massive massive cuban influence also a
lot of like pirate kind of [ __ ] yeah
because there was like a lot of you know
pirates of the caribbean
the food here is great you can find a
lot of [ __ ] here um like i said if
you're into cuban food i would
definitely recommend cuban indians
everything here yeah um orlando is a
real
it's a weird kind of city because it's
so
transient like it's so based around
tourism and like the disney parks and
everything like that people you know you
got people leaving california and if you
guys don't know me i was born in
california
a lot of people leave california they're
going to new york i
see excuse me a lot of them are leaving
california and they're going to
um texas all right some of them are
leaving texas and going back to
california because
they're going oh man the monoculture the
food isn't any good you know
texas and florida are very different
there are places in texas around the
austin area where there's
not a lot going on florida like
is another it feels like another country
it does it feels like a central american
country to me with a bunch of tourists
in it
um but it feels like a rich central
american country because a lot
haven't lived in brazil too it's a lot
higher end than brazil
okay but it does brazilians move here
and there
feel right at home they like it here um
it's just a good state good mixture of
stuff well there's a lot to be
i mean there's a lot that i don't like
about it the laws are real reasonable
too and the taxes and [ __ ]
it's good there's a lot that i don't
like about it because like i said i was
born here but
um you know i can see why people would
want to come here and
it depends where you want to go in
florida depends on what you like
um if you don't like rednecky [ __ ] i
would not recommend
um don't go above or uh daytona
no don't go anywhere in the panhandle um
because that's basically just like
[ __ ]
yeah don't eat yeah but they're having
fun up there well yeah but i'm just i'm
just saying if you like
rednecky [ __ ] then by all means like go
to the panhandle um
other than that i mean jacksonville is a
big city but jacksonville
the weird thing about jacksonville i
always i've only been there
my mom used to live there so i used to
go there every now and then
the weird thing about jacksonville is
that it's a real big city
um but it's very oh what's the word
for it it just seems really
straight laced it seems really uptight
like for a city it seems like a
corporate big city
does that make any sense no um i don't
know it just seemed like that to me like
it seems like a big city
but it didn't seem like any fun it
wasn't like
it wasn't like real vibrant or it wasn't
just that like button people glad yeah
it just seemed like i don't know every
time i went there like they used to have
a couple good clubs
um that i went to but i'm sure they're
long gone by now
but i just feel like when i was going
there it just felt very sterile
you know what i mean like it's a big
city but it just seemed very sterile
so yeah if you ask me everything depends
upon whatever scene you're into what
kind of friends you have that's really
what it all boils down to
well i mean you can find anything you
can find something to like no matter
where you are
i mean even when i was in daytona which
i hated
um there were like a small contingent
i mean we had like little tiny we had
like a little indie bookstore
we had like a little tiny punk rock club
we had a little
you know and we all knew each other
because it was only like [ __ ] you're
going to panhandle and you're up north
in florida [ __ ] really like things
going on is there's a couple there's
college town there
there might be some well gainesville is
kind of more in the
middle like it's north but central but
there used to be i don't know about it
there's also like a big mud trucking
events you know what i mean where
they're doing mudding and [ __ ] which is
you can just go look at florida [ __ ]
mud truck
stuff and it's just nothing but redneck
girls and bikinis and [ __ ] on these
damn mud trucks and they're getting
drunk it's stupid
but they love it yeah i mean they love
that which a lot of florida is like that
they're not gonna lie kind of [ __ ]
rap music and white girls with [ __ ]
butt all over them
zack said jenny i know you said
scientology ran clear water but what's
it like there otherwise
clear water it yeah it's a little bit
boring like the downtown
i'm kind of bummed that [ __ ]
scientology kind of took over the [ __ ]
and we're just like hey we're gonna put
up all we're gonna buy all the buildings
and then just make them so nobody ever
comes there anymore
because um you know the downtown was
actually quite beautiful like some of
the architecture and stuff
but what they did was they bought up i
don't think they own everything down
there
but they did buy up a bunch of the
buildings and make them into scientology
buildings and now there's like nothing
in there so nobody goes in there so
there's really not a reason to go down
there um but the beaches are gorgeous i
want
the west coast beaches because uh having
grown up in daytona which is east coast
um the beaches there are nice a lot of
people like them because you can drive
on them
you know they're good for like fishing
there's like cool like it's more like
tacky
kind of [ __ ] at least where i grew up
because there's like boardwalks and all
that kind of crap
the west coast beaches because it's the
gulf of mexico rather than the atlantic
like the beaches are way way prettier
because the water is way prettier it's
like
really blue is motorcycle heaven oh that
too i forgot motorcycle heaven
if you like harley's you can get those
cheap here used
[ __ ] yeah two times four motorcycles
two times a year in daytona they have
octoberfest yeah and
do you like guns florida is gun heaven
[ __ ]
uh they have real [ __ ] lacks gun laws
[ __ ]
it's there's not a [ __ ] crime is not
really through the roof here
yeah you have weird [ __ ] that happens
but it's not really a crime
infested place it's pretty happy it's
not
terrible i mean some places are
obviously worse than others and like
some there are some you're down there
than you deserved
you know you know what what you're you
know what i mean you know i mean it
depends i mean
there's some neighborhoods in orlando
that yeah yeah you probably shouldn't go
to
although downtown orlando safe
it's iffy no that's safe it's iffy yes i
mean we go down there all the time but
it's i think it's a little bit safer you
got to look at it from my point of view
compared to [ __ ]
new orleans oh [ __ ] so yeah compared
to anything in brazil
super safe compared to say la real safe
yeah are you talking about compared to
detroit [ __ ] right super safe
yeah very very safe i don't worry too
much about it every now and then
there's been a couple of there were a
couple little shootings that happened
around us you had the [ __ ] pulse
nightclub thing that was terrorism you
know what i mean but well and [ __ ] that
was only we were out that night too
there was yeah yeah that was that
happened like a couple blocks away from
where we were they kicked the dude out
of the club he went out to the car and
got a [ __ ] 22 and started shooting at
the back door and a friend of mine was
the bouncer was [ __ ]
keeping the [ __ ] door shut [ __ ] he
was blocking the bullets off
but you know what we laughed at that
we just kind of laughed that off nobody
got hurt and
and the cops he's not talking about
pulse he's talking about yeah
he's talking about eyebrow which is the
bar that we go with somebody did shoot
at the door somebody shoot at the door
and my friend [ __ ] was holding the
door
that was a long time a long time ago and
the cop station was next door to that
that dude immediately got arrested
that's what's kind of dumb it's like
yeah but it's [ __ ] okay
here's eye bar it's at the corner of
orange avenue and washington
it's like this it's on the corner it's
big yeah and then like right down here
on washington
there is a parking lot
another parking lot and then the police
station yeah
so you're gonna see stupid [ __ ] happen
like that but you know what i mean if
you if you're a kind of coward
that worries about that kind of [ __ ]
just stay your [ __ ] ass home
okay there's always the chance that
something bad could happen but that's
just life
that's life you know we don't work and
to
before i mean before me and you got
together
yeah um i used to go downtown by myself
all the time like i was usually i was
always going down there meeting people
it's not like i was just going down
there and hanging out by myself or
anything i was going down there and like
hanging out the bars and like i knew
everybody
but um i didn't really i felt unsafe
sometimes because sometimes you'd get
like some sketchy [ __ ] following
you or whatever and it's like it's
very different though but yeah so it's
it's kind of like that but
i've never woman crime that's very
different than [ __ ] dudes shooting
each other
well yeah here's the thing every time we
there were shootings and [ __ ] that
happened downtown and every time
these were not serious [ __ ] it
was always some dumbass
did something stupid all right it was
not really something real malicious
either
this is florida yeah i remember the dude
who
got so drunk the dumbass capitals
[Laughter]
in brazil it was very different if a
dude got shot it was some [ __ ]
malicious [ __ ] it was pre-planned by
[ __ ] professional
thieves that were trying to kill a dude
to get money that's not what it is in
in in florida well here it's just like
oh it's dude got drunk at the bar he had
a gun in his waistband
pulled it out and [ __ ] passed out on
the bar with a [ __ ] gun
on a [ __ ] remember that dude oh yeah
that's right then he then he got
they tried to lock him into the damn bar
he tries to get out walks down the
street with a gun in his hand [ __ ]
could barely stand up and the cops
[ __ ] blew him away
yeah yeah because like i said the cops
are like
literally around the corner and really
and literally right there
american cops will [ __ ] kill you
they will just [ __ ] kill you well
yeah they don't care what you're doing
either no you're good
sometimes that could be good and
sometimes that can be really bad
it's a double edge yeah so but um you
know
i have a very good sense of good and
evil and violence and [ __ ]
evil and warfare and stuff and
hanging out for years in downtown
orlando i never
felt i never felt
waves of evil or anybody being [ __ ]
totally like no malevolence it's usually
just somebody being stupid
yeah which like i said that can result
in the same thing it can result in
something getting better but
sure it's usually just [ __ ] stupid
stupid people
stupid people being dumb juan asked what
your age is
you're [ __ ] 51. he's 51.
um and i'm 48. i know you didn't ask
zach said
a favorite club you guys go to
independent bar um
there's a lot of clubs in orlando
there's
but independent bar has been there for
more than 30 years
um as i said it's right on the main drag
on the corner of orange and washington
right down the street from like church
street where all that kind of [ __ ] is
and i think the thing about it i think
that
the reason that it survived so long
because i've kind of thought about this
myself there's just something about that
place
that fosters
a feeling of i don't want to say it's
like you know like on cheers where it's
like you know so you come
you kind of come in you feel like oh
it's like your second home or whatever
eyebar has that kind of vibe to it well
that was our version of cbgb's really
yeah and it's a they do kind of like um
they've changed it a little bit over the
years but not too much
um saturday nights is always 80s new
wave
um they do momento mori which is goth
industrial they do that once
a month on a monday and then the rest of
the times
i don't know if they do because
sometimes they do indie they do
a night called mac and cheese yeah which
is 80s and 90s but it's like cheesy [ __ ]
like [ __ ] iced tea
like not iced tea but vanilla ice you
know what i mean like and tiffany and
that kind of [ __ ]
um yeah which people [ __ ] love that
man that's like full of [ __ ] 25 year
olds which is crazy
yeah but um so they do that i don't know
if they do that you can said eyebar he
knows
ken you know eye bar yeah i mean i don't
know i don't think they do grits and
gravy anymore because that was one thing
that i used to like it used to be
tuesdays and i think they moved it to
thursdays
grits and gravy used to be cool [ __ ]
from the 50s to the 70s so you could
feel this would be like elvis
and then they'd play like abba or like
something from greece or something like
it was like super super fun
and it attracted like i think the cool
thing about eyebar
is that it's kind of that place that
has been there so long but it's still
kind of cool so it's like
you can go out to any other club in the
air because there's tons of them
you go into another club but you're
always going to end up there at the end
of the night
because it's just kind of open to
everybody there's just always some
there's always something for any kind of
person there's been a lot of clubs come
and go over the [ __ ] decades oh big
time
you know what i mean uh some of them
were physically a lot better but then
they didn't last long
you know uh there's that one place what
was the places it's changed
names so many times it's where uh it's a
club but they used to have shows there
we saw
the social the no no the one
no no no i know what you're talking
about um it's had a couple different
names yeah what the [ __ ] is that called
now
uh i'll remember it you saw shows we saw
peter murphy there
we saw peter murphy there we saw gary
newman there or did we see him at that
other
we saw him no we saw gary newman at that
time it's a red there that's right
what's the name of that it's got a new
name now yeah i think it's called
we haven't been to there since you know
they've been [ __ ] up lately man
[ __ ] i hope this [ __ ] [ __ ] blows
over so the [ __ ] nightlife comes back
and then i must say i'm kind of
impressed that a lot of clubs have
managed to remain open yeah it's
ridiculous i mean i'm are still open
yeah they closed for a long time but
while they were closed because you know
we
we know the owner john gardner and um
while they were in
while they were shut down he actually
like put money into
improving he painted the whole ship yeah
he like put on there and he made it like
really it was nice
it's actually better than ever right now
yeah he really really did it out nice um
although you know um the best goth club
of course in in florida is the castle
that goes all the way back to the
[ __ ] saturday night live when they
were on there to say in [ __ ] what was
better orlando or if i could remember
that tampa yeah
because that was a big thing like the
god scene yeah between orlando and tampa
well because
the thing about i don't talk i don't
even know yeah i don't even know if
you'd so much call it a rivalry because
orlando and tampa i mean
from ibarr to the castle is what maybe
an hour and a half
maybe not even um an hour so you do kind
of get people driving back and forth for
different events
but there is a little bit of a
competition it's not as bad as it used
to be but there is a little bit of
competition between
orlando the castle is really good though
when we go i mean the thing about the
castle
and i i started going there back in the
late
90s maybe mid to late 90s i can't
remember now but i started going there
though when i was still living in
daytona i used to drive like
and make it a drink yeah if you don't
know tampa to daytona that's like
two and a half hours one way because
it's all the way across the state
daytona is on one end tampa's on the
other end
so you just take i-4 all the way across
so i used to every saturday night
and i couldn't afford to stay over in a
hotel this was when i was married to my
first husband
so we would never stay in a hotel we
would just go to the club for
several hours and then we'd drive back
at like five in the morning
so you know we didn't drink that much
back then which you know just to be
safe even though it's like there's
nobody on the [ __ ] road at that time
anyway
but the thing about the castle even
going back to like the 90s and the 2000s
i was not a massive fan of the music
i have to say i'm not i'm a very
old school i like
new wave i like post punk i like death
rock
i like punk rock i like that kind of
[ __ ]
so i feel like the castle a lot of their
stuff was industrial which is fine
or you know synth pop um
you know a lot of that kind of stuff
which again fine but not my favorite
so a lot of the times i would go there
like i would drive all the way there you
get like [ __ ] cause you gotta like
[ __ ] dress up if you're going to the
castle because it's the [ __ ] castle
and it was like a special occasion
so you have to super dress up you'd go
there
and then sometimes i'd be in there i'd
be drinking my whatever it was and they
have real glasses
not even plastic cups or anything and
you'd be sit and
i'd be like listen to the music being
like you know i'd be smoking my clothes
and i'd be like goddamn it's like i
really wish they'd play something that
didn't sound
the same like it sometimes it seemed
like [ __ ] two hours i'd be standing
there and be like this is the same song
it just feels like it's not changing
but you know what i mean it's like not
to pick on them but um i'm
you know we haven't been there in a
while i think the last time we went to
the castle was when
the vampire ball it's been about a year
at least
huh the vampire ball have we been there
since then
we haven't been we haven't been there
since the pandemic hit
well i know that but i think even before
that we hadn't been there for like many
years because
because remember we went i remember
going to the vampire ball
with jen and demetri yeah because we got
a hotel
because obviously it's tampa and dimitri
was like hey i work for the hotel chain
it's like we're all gonna stay over so
we all stayed in tampa like all weekend
and we went to the vampire ball man we
had the whole we were all [ __ ]
done out and uh that was a fun
event but the thing about the castle is
that it's so well known around the
country
is that you get when they do like
vampire ball or
a masquerade or something like that you
get people from everywhere
dj and that place is [ __ ] packed
maniacs
asking about fetish factory remember
finish factory yeah yeah that was kind
of like the heavier [ __ ] uh
that was like swingers and [ __ ] at that
one wasn't it
yeah that's what i think so because
wouldn't jenna dimitri [ __ ] hanging
out over there
no uh briana bechdu though brian beck
that's what it is yeah running back
yeah yeah yeah where do they have that
at do you know
um it moves around i think um
that's generally a south florida thing i
haven't been to go to that [ __ ]
you got to be willing to give up some
ass i haven't been to any fetish [ __ ]
for a really long time and
the fetish [ __ ] i feel like that's more
they do it up here too
but that's more a south florida thing
like they used to have
they had a club called man right down
here which i know it's i don't know if
it was affiliated with the one that uh
you knew about but there was one
it was in fort lauderdale yeah which you
know is not that far from miami
and i went to a fetish party there one
night and
they were like super strict i mean super
strict about dress code super strict
about everything because it was
you know oh well hey how did you come in
here she snuck in
how did you shut the door behind you
what yeah how'd that happen you broke it
did she break that one too yeah god damn
it
okay you bro i bought those i bought
those two floppy fish for them for
christmas one for her and one for beige
and she broke both of them broke that
one too
god damn it now i'm gonna have to give
they're not that expensive they're only
like six boxers
why you break the fishy why'd you break
it she's like
she was looking up and i'm like what i
didn't do anything
you broke the fishies
[Laughter]
she always has this little look well
like when she listens on her face
yeah she stripped it
[Laughter]
that looks dirty but it looks like a
[ __ ] sex toy
but yeah
ridiculous it is but yeah so
yeah so that was a long time ago so the
castle
is um in case you've never seen it
i think the one of the reasons one of
the main reasons why it's such an
iconic uh club or in the gossip around
the country
is because of that [ __ ] building that
building
is amazing yes and it was a cat it was
like a it was a
cigar factory or a it looks like a damn
masonic block or a masonic lodge or
something that's what it looks like to
me
it's uh it's big and it's it takes up
like a whole
corner and it's kind of off on its own
it's not
on the main drag and actually when i
used to go there it used to be a lot
more secluded because
since i started going there in the late
90s early 2000s
they built out this whole thing called
centro ebore
which is all kind of like this big open
like mezzanine or whatever and
like they have all these like
restaurants and shops and all this other
kind of [ __ ] because they're trying to
open up to more tourism
in ybor city so so it they opened the
castle up
you know so across the street there's
like this big [ __ ]
open air there's restaurants and all
kind of crap so they didn't that didn't
used to be there
um so when you waited in line for the
castle we were kind of because
there's a there's a main strip in ebore
7th avenue
and that's where most of the like kind
of mainstream clubs are
so the nice thing about the castle was
that it was a couple blocks off that
it's like at 9th and 16th
so you could kind of like go a little
bit off the beaten path you know the
where the castle is like there's just
like a dead end like right in front of
it
um so you didn't get people like just
wandering in
so much um i'm sure you probably do now
because now it's all open and
you get all the lookie-loos coming into
from the restaurant going oh what's that
over there you know what i mean then
wandering in there
so i'm sure it probably sucks now i
don't know
but um so it used to be a lot more
secluded because it was just like
abandoned
buildings or apartments or something
opposite
but i don't know it just seems like that
building
it's real it's really big and it's like
the ground floor it's like
the bar on the ground floor is amazing
i don't know who made it but it's just
like
it's this black it almost looks like
obsidian or some [ __ ] like that
and it's all the way around it's like
u-shaped and it has like all these
little channels in it
like with like water running through it
and [ __ ] like that and it's just like
really dark and it's all atmospheric and
[ __ ] and then you go
they have music down there then they
have a big patio and then you go
upstairs and that's where like all the
uh you know goth industrial [ __ ] is and
they have like stained glass windows
it's [ __ ] gorgeous
um so i think that i mean they used to
have
more it used to look more gothy i feel
like because they had like velvet
couches and you could like lay over
there and smoke your clothes and be all
like cool and everything yeah but they
kind of
well back in the day but what they did
was they kind of opened it up more to
like the fetish scene because i guess
that's where more of their money was
coming from so they built a dungeon
in the uh in the ground floor which is
limited access you can go in there if
you have like special thing
would in an event or whatever they don't
open it all the time there's cages in
there where you can play
with [ __ ] and whatever they have like
you can can't you like
tie people up on the wall and what i
don't know i don't really pay attention
to it so they have all that kind of
stuff down there and then
up on the upper floor where it's kind of
sucks because they used to have like all
these nice like conversation pits with
all these velvet couches and stuff
and now they just have like more cages
and like more fetish stuff
which you know whatever that's that's
where the money last time we were there
remember the management was [ __ ] up
that's true i haven't been there a long
time yeah
it's just you know britney says cages
you can play with yeah there's like
little cages yeah they had all that
going on and then upstairs was dance
floor
it was just it was just a cool club uh
just
remember the last time we we were there
for an event
the woman that was running the [ __ ]
downstairs was [ __ ] up and the
management was kind of [ __ ] up you
know i mean it looked like they didn't
know what was going on and
i don't know we haven't been there in a
while it's maybe they've straightened it
out well
we'll have to see yeah i mean i wouldn't
mind going to like if you know
if they have like a big event again
because they do have really nice
big events there like i said they do a
vampire ball big events have been on
hold for the past year i know but see
we're gonna see what's going on but i
think that might have been the last time
we went was the last time they did a
vampire ball
yeah um which i think is isn't that the
same one that they sometimes do in new
orleans or no
i can't remember we went to it two years
yeah
like i don't remember if it was two
years in a row or if it was a year in
between
but um wouldn't mind going back to new
orleans
well i've never been so we should
probably go at some point
britney says uh sounds like a good time
to me it is
the and the thing about it is that
it's tampa is you know far enough away
that you know the castle is kind of like
a treat
so when you're going there it's kind of
like an event you know it's like oh we
really really got to dress up and we got
to get a hotel room and
you got to like plan a whole weekend
around it because it's
you know it's not a huge drive for us
it's about
i think it's an hour and a half hour 45
minutes something like that
um so you know but it's a cool place
it's it's really hard to
it's hard to explain what the atmosphere
is like if you've never been there
and if you're not like if you're not
really into gothy [ __ ] it might not
they wouldn't like impress you so much
but
for little goth kids like me like i said
when i was still
in my 20s and 30s you know in the 90s
and early 2000s
i mean when i went there i was just like
oh this is everything i ever wanted it's
like it looked exactly like i pictured
you know going to a goth club like if
you saw in a movie or something like it
looks exactly like that
like all the people that work there and
like all the just the whole atmosphere
of it that's exactly what you would
picture
how long we've been streaming just say
hour and 28 minutes okay
zach says i don't think fetish anything
exists here in indiana
uh you might be surprised there's fetish
[ __ ] everywhere
it's just depends on what state it is
you just have to like
look a little deeper although i will say
we have i mean there are a lot of fetish
clubs here
or at least there used to be i don't
know about nowadays um
i do feel like maybe in smaller state
like you know states where it's not so
uh prevalent or cities where it's not so
prevalent
it might kind of get into a thing where
i don't know you're getting into like
the weird swinger thing and like oh
everything's like
[ __ ] 60 year old naked dudes
see there's a difference between fetish
fashion and fetish reality
a lot of the [ __ ] [ __ ] that we go to
is more like just a fashion but it's
more like a goth night and with
industrial music
um but they do have some damn [ __ ]
places where they
where it's a [ __ ] swingers [ __ ]
event
and uh it's a bunch of old floppy people
[ __ ] you
you one anything to do with that [ __ ]
that's what i mean it's really
that's the thing there's a lot of
overlap between the goth industrial
scene
and between and the fetish scenes but
there is still it's mostly fashion worth
anything that's what i mean it's not
like you know the venn diagram is not
like a complete circle there's still
like a little bit of
you know separate [ __ ] yeah because i
feel like
a lot of goth industrial people um
they like the look of the [ __ ] you know
they like all the bdsm like looking
clothing
and some of them are into some of that
[ __ ] you know what i mean
um just roll mild kind of [ __ ] but
i feel like in the fetish community you
have some of that
but then you also have like these normal
looking
old people todd said don't be don't be
putting down 60 year old dudes tom's
nearly 60. i'm not nearly
60 you [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
maybe the big picture but come on rick
says i'm looking for a floppy goth
i don't know if we know any do we know
any floppy guys not everybody people
don't age all the same bro
that's true yeah it is i'm 51 i'm still
[ __ ] holding my own man
well we're still trying to keep it
together we actually
we went to momentum we go to the [ __ ]
clubs young people look like [ __ ]
compared to us half of them
we went to memento mori a few weeks ago
yeah we had masks on everything it's all
right everybody
you know everybody had messed it's fine
but um
so we went to that and i was i mean i
got i was pretty drunk but i was like i
was talking to this one guy
i don't know how old he was and he just
kept coming up to the bar
and he was like talking to me and he's
like hey what the [ __ ]
like i was talking to him and he asked
me how old i was
and it's weird because like i love
telling people how old i am
at that bar because for some reason they
never believe me
i'm old though yeah and then they're
like yeah bye
[Laughter]
because you're old enough to be my mom
that's gross
it's not what it was just because i was
there too and he realized the [ __ ] it
was all just a bunch of [ __ ] old
people
that does kind of well that happened a
lot like before like
you guys can't lie to you see that's the
deal
no one can lie to me he can't lie to me
well you can but
you'll pay for it later before and
you'll figure it out
you'll pay for it later because i will
figure out like some epically [ __ ]
what day is it today is wednesday right
it's wednesday okay
i'm getting sick of being in the house
man soon as soon as i [ __ ] heal up
i'm gonna start partying again
[ __ ] these lockdowns we're not locked
down here
they're not even being stripped about
the masks i'm going to start doing
whatever the [ __ ] i want to do
you're going to spread your i'm
spreading diseases whatever i want to do
yeah i'm going to do whatever
time i'll do whatever i want i don't
care
more y'all to die the [ __ ] more [ __ ]
there is for me to take
so i'm gonna look at it that's nice yeah
i'm like mad max
okay i don't give a [ __ ] world's over
already
your [ __ ] is gonna be mine it's really
nice take it from you you're not taking
my [ __ ]
no not you i'm talking these
[ __ ] i'm going to take it
i'm sure everybody in there is like yeah
either whatever you have it should be
mine i can't understand why you have it
that's that's my new method you sound
like one of those dudes in the movie
exactly that's
that that just
i can't understand why you have that
that's supposed to be mine that's gonna
be my whole [ __ ]
that's gonna be my new philosophy i
don't know if that's such a good
philosophy
not worried about good or bad anymore
my time is short i'm like the devil the
woe that the devil had beast the wrath
or he knows the time
zach says tom's giving the world his
cooties um
zach says none of you are allowed to
complain i look both 12
and 40 at the same time god damn
zack said that yeah zach's just trying
to be gay
you're just trying he's not trying to be
gay he's good okay he's not trying he's
doing it
he's a doer yeah he's a dude
see i brought that right back i got that
right back sad as gay as you is
you still need to lose that belly you
were telling me
about all that weight that you gained
just sitting around
being gay in the middle of a pandemic
you can't you can't do that man
sitting around being gay in the middle
of a pandemic
you gotta understand that a gay man is
supposed to have gay man is supposed to
have standards
okay go on a diet lose the [ __ ]
weight
get your [ __ ] vacuum pump get that
big
dick as big as it can get
[Laughter]
he's giving advice now that's my advice
get an injection
get it get any kind of ejections you
need
fido says like all those gay gandalf so
he was watching yesterday
you don't understand zach the way i
understand zack
hi poop zach is a [ __ ]
megalomaniac [ __ ] gay power bottom
all right he will [ __ ] jump on a fire
hydrant and just work it up and down
like that
i got the [ __ ] on video he sent it to me
really
yeah yeah did he show it to you no why
are you flinging your glasses at me
i'm making things up okay
don't interrupt me i'm pulling [ __ ] out
of my
[Laughter]
god house i'm trying i know i'm trying
to tell a good story such an [ __ ]
trying to tell a good story and she's
fact checking me
jenny's fact checking i know i'm
terrible
facts should totally not matter don't
check any facts
it'll only lead to ruin
[Laughter]
man i was hoping that i'd wake up this
morning feeling good because
jenny is my witness last night i was
talking about koi wan
yeah the chinese chef at chinese buffet
and i was gonna attack the chuffy
the chocolate chip [ __ ] you [ __ ]
that's how he shortened it
i'm trying to [ __ ] tell a story okay
that chinese buffet was [ __ ] calling
me
okay it was calling me from across the
[ __ ] waves you know what i'm talking
about
well from across like you know a couple
miles yeah of highway sure
damn i want some chinese buffet he was
yeah
with the crab legs and the [ __ ]
boiled shrimp
and then i started to think about all
the indian buffets we've been missing
out on
losing too much weight me and jenny are
getting skinny on this [ __ ] well i'm
trying to lose weight
he doesn't want to hear it i'm trying to
lose weight
we got to get pretty again well yeah for
florida
yeah i can't this is this isn't
sustainable it's not sustainable
i have to like seriously no it's not and
like
i i have a tendency like i told you man
i just sniff food and i
gain weight so i have to kind of like
today
this is what i've eaten today i ate one
hard-boiled egg
i had a mug full of leek soup and a
protein bar
that's it and i walked five miles yeah i
ate leek soup
and then i had uh a half of a [ __ ]
pita bread pita ham and [ __ ] man i can't
even talk
ham and cheese holy crap how strong
sandwich on peter
add a half a pita that's pretty good
yeah
you know what's weird though i kind of
felt and i felt this today when i was
doing my
five mile because yeah they they feel it
they're going look at look at brittany's
like man i've missed chinese buffet hell
yes i miss all that [ __ ]
well we discovered that koi won was
still open like to a limited extent it's
open
and the [ __ ] buffet is rolling at koi
won
but they're like taking precautions
obviously yeah because i mean
buffets are jeremy at the best of times
but you know
um so this morning when i was out
because yesterday i did a three mile
hike with a 25 pound backpack
um and yesterday i think i only ate
a protein bar and one no i didn't even
need a protein bar i ate a bowl of
leek soup and a cup of coffee and that's
it
so so i did that and then today when i
was out doing my five mile walk
when i was walking i thought to myself
i feel amazing
yeah i felt so good
that it was like i was like euphoric
you know what i mean and i haven't felt
like that for like a really long
time not eating that much yeah i don't
know yeah because i think the thing
about
my metabolism is very weird and it took
me a long time to realize this
now ken says tom's philosophy is what's
yours
is mine and what mine is mine that's
right ken
that's the philosophy i have i wish it
was a reality
because it's not real it's a fantasy
he just wants everyone's [ __ ] i wish all
your [ __ ] was my [ __ ]
when i do take some [ __ ] every now and
then i [ __ ] go well yeah that's
because i deserve that
you know what i mean but unfortunately
i'm i'm i'm [ __ ] i'm like i'm like
y'all i'm just trying to make it from
one day to the next you know what i mean
well there's nothing wrong with that
yeah we're all in the same boat bro yeah
you know it's time i wouldn't take
anybody else's [ __ ] because like the
[ __ ] man they might be in worse
situation than me
i don't want to [ __ ] him over even worse
it's time for a comeback though
it's time for a comeback i'm tired of
being in this house man
tired of being in this house pandemic
[ __ ] yeah i'm tired of
being here with the pandemics and all
this [ __ ] when you start making some
[ __ ] money
all these states need to open up when
you start [ __ ] making the money i
don't give a [ __ ] about these people man
come on he just wants everyone to die so
he can
so i can take this do whatever he wants
yeah okay just you know i'm not worried
about pandemics
average the average age of anybody dying
in these pandemics is 83.
okay but like you should have been dead
if you die of covid
um i'm gonna remind you that you said
that it's okay i know i'm ready i'm
ready to roll those dice i'll roll those
dice all the time but you see me roll
the dice so
phil gardner says this movie really got
into tom's head
it did it gave him some ideas mike's
going man
good thing i gave tom that move you
haven't influenced him i know right it's
like
holy [ __ ] now he's gonna like start
kidnapping people what am i gonna do if
he like brings somebody to the house and
like respects me to like torture them
and [ __ ] actually what does
what those dudes did actually [ __ ]
there was a lot of labor involved in
that
you know what i mean it seems like it
would be easier and more easier
make honest money there's there's easier
ways to make things
that's the thing okay like if your
criminal enterprise
it has that many moving parts yeah i'm
like just get a job
well don't you realize what the the dude
the dude that they were tortured to try
to get all this money
his money was coming from a deli yeah
well among other things
but that wasn't the only business but
that was one of his main businesses
open up a goddamn deli he owned a
franchise yeah yeah yeah
i mean like i said they didn't go into
that in the movie but he did own like a
bunch of other companies too
but uh yeah so they like they just brick
and mortar businesses can be rough
um well restaurants are the darkest is
the
restaurant even before all this happened
that was like
what was it like only five ten percent
of them like survive past
a year or two if you
if i were to open any kind of brick and
mortar business or a physical business
and it was a restaurant it would not be
a restaurant per se
it would be a food truck i would rather
have a food truck i'd much rather have a
food food truck i mean that's a much
lower
you're not limited you're not limited by
well yeah and it's a much lower
investment obviously and you can have
like a much more limited menu
yeah i mean look how well small
excellent menu you
move it around you find where uh people
are working
guys on the construction sites and you
show up and you sell
some [ __ ] lunch right there at the
construction zone that's how i mean i
don't know about nowadays but
a few years ago um there was a [ __ ]
cupcake truck
that went around orlando cupcake truck
and that was
that i don't know if they're like out of
business now but i mean that
did like amazing business the cupcake
truck get did so much good business that
the the city of orlando
banned food trucks well because they
were taking business away from the
restaurants
right and like the restaurant owners
were complaining because they're like
look the food trucks come down here and
park
and we can't compete because their
overheads are so much lower
food truck is the way to go you only
want three things
three or four things on the menu that
[ __ ] dominate
at a great price point and you go out
and you make your score and then you
come back
and you [ __ ] clean your truck i feel
like if you're going to do a restaurant
i always just feel like and we've talked
about this before because we watch like
all gordon ramsay [ __ ] and we're like
fascinated by that kind of stuff venue's
too limited
well i feel like if you're going to if
you really want to make an impact
you have to just focus on
one thing yeah and just do it
better than anybody the problem with
restaurants is that restaurants are
location based
everything is location location location
location if your location is not perfect
your restaurant is not perfect if you've
got a shitty location
you gotta [ __ ] that menu has to be
fine-tuned to that shitty location
and so that people will come there
specifically for that one
thing that you do there are a couple of
uh
cuban restaurants that are in shitty
locations low-income
locations that [ __ ] boom because they
sell one thing
and that is a cuban lunch or a cuban
dinner
that's it and it's cheap because every
cuban will come from that area
and it's almost kind of like going
through a damn chow hall it's beans and
rice and some kind of pork
beans rice and pork beans rice and pork
over and over and over again
and for four bucks you can [ __ ] eat
your fill
and yeah they're doing well is it a nice
restaurant no
no no no it's not a nice restaurant but
is the food good yeah it's good it's
good
it's making a good profit
fine tunes to that one thing
feeding the neighborhood you know
i really do feel like if you're going
because being in the restaurant business
is so hard even before the pandemic and
everything like that
like it was the hardest you know retail
type business there was
because there's so many there's so much
competition and especially nowadays yeah
and i feel like the mistake that a lot
of people made
maybe not so much nowadays but used to
see this like i said we watch [ __ ]
kitchen nightmares and all that kind of
crap
like a lot of the mistake that they
would make was that they tried to please
everybody like so they would try to have
this massive
menu it's like hey let's put all of this
[ __ ] on here like why not and the whole
[ __ ] the menu is like [ __ ] 30 pages
long
i think italian restaurants were the
worst culprits for that but i saw other
restaurants doing it too
and they would just they would just put
everything on there it's like oh one
person told me they wanted this so i put
it on there
and it's like if you have like 100
dishes on your [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're not gonna be no you know the menu
the more money
money you're losing yeah because it's
like you're not focusing on any one
thing it's like everything is just gonna
be
okay or mediocre to shitty
sophie's in how you doing sophie hey
there you are you doing the research
stuff
quit picking on her yeah um that is
saying the movie got in my head
uh omega man tom fido has called me fido
montoys call me
omega man tom omega manta omega time
yeah uh
but yeah what was that i i feel like i
was saying something about
weight loss everybody's talking it was
weight loss and then all of a sudden
they're talking about food and
everybody's hungry
and then trucks sorry um yeah
well that's the thing it's like i really
have to i'm and it took me like
probably 35 years to learn this is that
my particular body for whatever reason
it feels much better like the less it
eats
as long as i'm not starving
um if i just eat like a little bit
like every three four hours like a
little bit
like a like a cup of soup or a protein
bar
or something like that um i feel much
better than if i eat like a big
i mean i told you this morning yesterday
i ate almost nothing like i did eat i'm
not starving
but this morning i was out walking and i
was like holy [ __ ] man i could walk all
day
i feel like [ __ ] superwoman it's
because you're burning your fat reserves
yeah it felt really really good so you
know
it's that's just kind of like what i
don't know why i just feel so much
better like when i don't eat all that
much
i mean i love to eat i'm not saying that
and i love food
and i love fattening food yeah but i
miss it man i gotta get back to eating
but my brain and my body are at uh
at cross purposes you know what i'm
saying
well we've always kind of gone through
these cycles of [ __ ] losing weight
gain away
eating and dieting and you know what i
mean it's just kind of which i've tried
not to do that because my mom did that
her whole life and it's like i just
really
wanted to like not do that that's the
way it is yeah
but it's really hard not to because it's
hard to
it's hard to maintain um because like i
said i started doing
um intermittent fasting which like i
said
is basically you can do it there's you
know two or three different
ways you can do it you can do it like oh
you know a couple days a week i don't
need anything and then the rest of the
time i eat like reasonably
or you can do like oh this day i'm going
to eat 2 000 calories this time and eat
500 calories and you can like switch out
what i found works best for me is that
every day
you only have an eight hour window to
eat and then there's a 16 hour window
where you don't eat anything
now you can choose whenever you want
that eight hour window to be
it can be mine is 10 a.m to 6 p.m
so you can eat i don't eat whatever i
want because i'm careful
but if you eat between 10 of you you
can't eat after 6 p.m
and you can't eat before 10 a.m if y'all
are enjoying the show please send us a
super chat
been on here for about a two almost an
hour and a half two hours and haven't
had a single super chat
it's about time for uh us to get a
couple of them flash bulbs
if you have any kind of questions you
want to ask us you can send us a
question and we will change
the topic of the show towards something
that you want to talk about
um just anything you know how it is i'm
passing around the collection
graham says alcohol has [ __ ] tons of
calories which is why
a lot of calories i didn't eat that much
today because i knew that i would be
having a couple drinks tonight so i
didn't eat that yesterday because i knew
that i would be compensating oh
man so you know but i haven't i haven't
had any alcohol since
saturday i'm missing brazilian food yeah
i'm gonna make some cochina little
[ __ ]
little little chicken do you know what's
weird i was watching
masterchef last time i'm watching master
chef season 10
on hulu and
one of the ladies on there made
french toast yeah and i was like man
don't i don't i haven't had french toast
and like what oh my goodness okay
what you guys you take french toast
right okay and you make a ham
swiss cheese and turkey sandwich okay
but yeah
with a little bit of [ __ ] corn see
this is why
i gained so much weight because because
sometimes
i'm like dude i just want like plain
french toast with like some spray butter
and a tiny little scosche of syrup on it
but he's like no we have to put eggs and
bacon and ham
and sugar and all this other stuff it's
like dude really we don't really need
all that stuff on there it's like can we
just have like just a simple
we just can't do that okay pookie what
are you doing what the [ __ ]
i noticed she wants to go out she wants
to go outside all right poke i'll let
you out
it's only it's 6 41. she hasn't been
outside don't let her go far
she doesn't go far she basically either
stays on the back porch stays on the
front porch
or sits in the neighbor's bushes or
yesterday
there is a little like our backyards
us and the like the three subsequent
neighbors
our backyards are kind of there's no
fences or anything in between so it's
just open
and there's a little bitty pond it's not
a lake or anything it's like a glorified
puddle reel
really and she was down there sitting by
the
bank and there's little bitty fish in
there and she was watching that she was
like trying to catch
the little fish they were like popping
out of the [ __ ] pond
so that's about as far as she goes every
now and then she'll go
under the fence but there's a fence and
then there's
a little bit of a little strip of woods
and then there's like the trail
that i walk on so and then there's like
another bit of woods and then there's a
road so
she's never been that far mostly she'll
go under the fence and then she'll just
sit
and like watch people going by like on
the trail
which i don't like it but
i got outvoted i didn't want to when we
got her as a kitten i was like can we
please like not let her go outside
but you know that's not what happened so
you know
yeah zack says slow metabolism
see i feel like as soon as i hit puberty
man
because i was skinny when i was a kid
real skinny
um all my siblings were also skinny when
we were kids
then as soon as we hit puberty we just
plumped right out
and then it was like really really hard
to
i mean when i was in high school i was
like man [ __ ] it i don't like pe i don't
like
that kind of [ __ ] i was i'm more of a
like [ __ ] you know
i'm more of a like intellect i want to
read and like [ __ ]
do art and make things i don't want to
like [ __ ] run around [ __ ] that
so you know i gained a lot of weight
then i met my first husband when i
was 22 i want to say
and he was real it was real he was real
skinny and he was like real into fitness
like a soccer player and a runner and
[ __ ] so i kind of got into that for a
little while and then i lost a bunch of
weight
and then just slowly over time it kind
of creeps up it's like
it's not even anything that you do
because i feel like a lot of times i'm
not eating an unreasonable amount
because i see other people
eating this is like really funny but
it's like
sometimes i see people eating like
skinny people
i'll see them like in a restaurant or in
starbucks or something
like i'll see a skinny girl in starbucks
and she has this [ __ ] venti
caramel macchiato with whipped cream and
also i'm like [ __ ]
are you gonna throw that up later it's
like how does that work
i'm not allowed to do that it's like how
does that happen
because i feel like because i feel like
i see people like skinny people like
eating
regular amounts of food and i just feel
like i'm not allowed to do that because
if i ate a regular amount of food i
would weigh 400 pounds
you know what i'm saying so you know i
have a little resentment about it
not saying that but it's genetic what
are you going to do about it
two probably to some extent
look at him look at everybody talking
about dj everybody's talking about how
fat or skinny they are
i at one point i got down
this was right around the time
so if we start like she's fat so so oh
my god
sophie no no sweetie honey
well she did games yes he did gain some
weight from the coven thing of what
being depressed up in the house but it's
still not the same as being fat
um yeah that's that's not even yeah
like i'm not in a couple of so you need
to come back and see us in a couple
months too once all this [ __ ] blows over
we need when when florida starts [ __ ]
rocking
and [ __ ] everything starts coming
back i'm hoping this [ __ ] will start
[ __ ] coming back soon it'll be all
right you'd have a [ __ ] blast over
here
and [ __ ] the business will probably
make more money then we'll see we'll see
we'll see but yeah so
what was i saying um i forgot what i was
saying talking about
sophie getting fat i know but like right
before
that i was talking about something else
and i don't remember oh thank oh my gosh
thank you joe
thanks joe from aka dark skull yeah yeah
yeah
oh thank you so much our first time
thank you man i'm trying to get some
super chats
finally get some super chats are up here
working and [ __ ] joe comes in and
throws a [ __ ] twenty dollars i'm
having a good time though i love this
[ __ ]
we're having a good time having a good
time we're hoping that you guys look
good i look forward to these
if i can hand out drinks i got enough
booze here to hand out drinks to
everybody in the chat right now
we have so much booze here that it would
be great
then i would be dead by the morning we'd
be having a [ __ ] house party in here
which the only thing i don't have is a
pool
well the community has something it has
a pool and the neighbor has a pool
wait is there there's somebody living
there right there's a second super chat
ain't that some [ __ ] oh
thank you ken can't yeah thanks ken
we could go over we can maybe go i don't
know no they won't let us actually he's
pretty cool
he just painted his house i was talking
to him the other day they make a lot of
noise though
well another dogs do yeah wait is that
their dog
yeah it's their dog is that their kid
yeah okay
because here's the thing here's my
office the window is right there
thank you tammy the window is right
there
and their house is
maybe 10 feet away yeah like their
backyard and they have a pool and it's
like a little bit of a
it's like everybody's buying us a drink
that's awesome thanks everybody
that right there made the [ __ ] night
worth it just [ __ ] just to um
just to have a uh a few super chats i'm
sorry people i'm [ __ ] loaded i can't
even [ __ ] finish some supper chat
so something like fresh sports but yeah
so
i wish you guys were over here we're
[ __ ] i'd pass out drinks we'd all
[ __ ] have a good time
yeah but well you know we're having it's
not even hot outside went outside
what are you talking about it's like 80
degrees no it's mild is it yes
okay it was maybe about 72 when we first
started maybe 50
humidity only yeah i went out this
morning
at seven and it was
70 something degrees and it was really
it was humid because it was super foggy
yeah not unpleasant
but it's not like january it's not like
winter time
it's kind of like
really like i wore a sleeveless shirt
and i was totally fine
but yeah so what i was saying it's like
the neighbor is like right there so
anytime they do yard work
or their kid is outside in the pool or
their dog is outside
i can hear it like it's right in the
[ __ ] room yeah
so you know this is weird because these
houses are like
kind of expensive but tila showed up how
you doing t
the walls are like paper thin yeah i can
hear everything that's going on next
door
t says he just got the night off yeah
all right
well [ __ ] we can't leave now yeah i
can't leave now
t we were talking about we were talking
about this movie all night
if you haven't seen this one you need to
see this one and like look into the real
case that inspired that
it's a true life it's a true it's a it's
the most florida thing that you have
ever heard of
it's a true crime story
happening in florida down in [ __ ]
miami
some muscle heads in a gym decide to
[ __ ] become millionaires
by kidnapping a rich
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] rich venezuelan
rich colombian jewish guy and they were
going to steal all his [ __ ] they still
all it's the
and this [ __ ] is funny as [ __ ] also they
murdered some people
yeah funny as [ __ ] though
but the movie is funny it's a michael
bay movie it's a low budget michael bay
movie that knocks it out of the park
relatively low with the rock it's got
the rock on it
it's got [ __ ] dwayne johnson
dwayne johnson is a rock yeah it's got
dwayne johnson
it's got mark wahlberg in it and it's
got
anthony mackey anthony mackie knocks it
out of the park like a [ __ ] young
like a like a young
eddie murphy really i know what you're
doing it's [ __ ] great man yeah
imagine a young eddie murphy on roy's on
roid rage
shit's [ __ ] hilarious yeah um but
it's just good flick
um it's a good dark comedy
bay [ __ ] he just nailed the tone
nailed the tone
to where it's like some horrible [ __ ]
happens but it's still
hilarious just because you're seeing
everything from the criminal's point of
view
and the criminals are dumb as rocks yeah
she's likable
they think they're kind of smart likable
dumbest [ __ ]
criminals trying to [ __ ] make
come up in the world down in miami
and they [ __ ] kill people they do
stupid [ __ ]
but there's still something kind of
funny about it even though there's
something kind of horrible
horrible about it it's just the tongue
was perfect
yeah they really they really did kind of
nail it
i felt kind of bad but not bad enough
that i wasn't like shrieking with
laughter
well they said they were trying to match
the tone of the people that
actually did all the investigations and
went through the trial
because they were laughing about this
[ __ ] it was just what happens when
[ __ ]
losers
[Laughter]
when losers try to make it in the big
time
yeah they're punching way above their
weight but not but in a way that they
fall down
yeah pathetically and yeah flail they're
still kind of they're still kind of
lovable they're
they're they're not i kind of think
that's what makes it work maybe
yeah graham asked can you hear the
cockroaches holding hands
well i don't know about that but you can
hear cockroaches
crawling across the wall though not here
not in this house i have heard that well
in my old house that i lived
in this house because every now and then
you would wake up in the middle of the
night and you would hear
yeah you'd hear that
and i'd be like oh [ __ ] there's a
[ __ ] roach in here
joe yeah i [ __ ] i'm glad you're having a
better time [ __ ] joe
yeah i'm feeling a little bit better
alcohol's starting to kick in
i i'm i'm i'm drunk sick i'm sick drunk
i was sick and now that i'm drunk i feel
a little bit better drink
drip
[Laughter]
or shrunk i don't know i don't know what
you would call it
alcohol is good for your because i feel
like because
i had that [ __ ] too but i feel like it
only lasted
approximately eight hours yeah um and it
was very mild and then it just kind of
went away and then i was like i hate to
tell you this but i feel pretty awesome
yes so my system is probably too toxic
for even covid to survive
he says marky mark and the rock i'm
there add it to my watch list
victor i think marky mark is mark
wahlberg well yeah
that's the joke that he said the wrong
dwayne johnson mark i love doing boogie
nights and rock stars and you will love
this movie
yeah he's it's very much a very much a
digler kind of vibe that he's giving off
in this like i said
somebody that's an idiot but that
doesn't know they're an idiot
yeah [ __ ] mark plays a guy
who is a [ __ ] kind of like a
he's a two-bit guy in florida down in
miami
all right and he's working at a at a gym
and he's a personal trainer he's [ __ ]
jacked
and he goes and he he's very optimistic
in life and he goes to see a [ __ ]
motivational speaker
who's kind of like a [ __ ]
it's i'm thinking it was probably oh
what's his name
[ __ ] what was that motivational
speaker's name [ __ ]
from the from tony i think it was tony
robbins from the [ __ ]
it might have been zig ziglar it might
have been zig ziglar although
there was a lot of motivational speakers
going because here's the thing like in
the 90s
i worked at a lot of like you know
corporate or corporate adjacent jobs
and there were a lot of those kind of
life coach
you know corporate kind of that was
there was all of that going around that
was like a very big thing
so i feel like so i feel like that might
have been
i don't know i just i i think of zig
ziglar because
uh a manager that we had was really
really into him
like had all his books and stuff so he
goes and i just thought it was very he
goes to this anthony robbins style
[ __ ] motivational [ __ ] course and
his head gets
big as [ __ ] he's gonna become like this
[ __ ] rich and famous
[ __ ] i'm a doer yeah i'm a doer i'm
not a daughter yeah i'm gonna actually
do this [ __ ]
south florida got a hold of his ass all
right and he wants to have a mansions
and a big
and a big [ __ ] you know fast cars and
crap
he wants to do blow up so of course the
only way you're gonna do that as a
[ __ ] muscle head is to [ __ ]
kidnap some rich dude and make him sign
over all his [ __ ] which he does
they kidnapped this dude to make him
sign over all his [ __ ] [ __ ] the rocks
there
it's just it's a great movie the whole
show tonight was about this movie
well more or less we went off and it is
a true story this ha
actually did happen largely it is some
of it's exaggerated but
not true i'm sorry not much and uh and
it's a michael bay movie it's a low
budget michael bay movie
but michael bay knocks it out of the
[ __ ] park
and the entire cast knock it out of the
[ __ ] park
and what's funny is that they got they
got wahlberg and they got [ __ ]
they got [ __ ] dwayne johnson on there
but really the third guy was anthony
mackie
yeah he should have been there too he's
kind of like his agent should say
they're like what the [ __ ] that'll suit
that [ __ ] wait well i'm blacky i can't
be on the cover yeah it's like what only
white dudes came on the cover
anthony mackie is the [ __ ] he plays
he plays a role that he plays a role
that [ __ ] a young eddie murphy would
have played
back in the 80s and they [ __ ] knock
it out of the park
and the three dudes go out and they try
this big [ __ ] caper
they get caught of course but that's
that's that's all true crime oh they got
caught because they're
yeah retired they were [ __ ] [ __ ]
but this [ __ ] was funny as [ __ ]
and the floor and the movie is florida
as [ __ ] florida as [ __ ]
it is you can't get more floor than than
that
like i said other than that dude even
eating that other dude's face off i
don't know
well okay no you can get more florida
than that because
if there was someone let's just have a
hypothetical exam
and to be honest i'm from florida i'm
sure this has probably happened at some
point
so some dude with a mullet tell some
other dude with a mullet
that he has made a let's see a pumpkin
cannon okay and um so they do that and
then it messes up his uh el camino
and then they get in a gun battle and
then
that guy kills that other dude's wife
and then
cuts her up and feeds her to alligators
and then
you know what i mean so it's like so
there could be a more florida thing and
like i said the thing that i just said
i'm sure that could probably happen at
some point
but this is one of the most florida
things
that has ever happened or ever will
happen like i said i'm surprised more
alligators weren't involved
although the everglades were involved
because the two people that they killed
um
they did cut them up put them in barrels
at least parts of them
um and put them in the everglades
although alligators couldn't get to them
because they were in barrels and
alligators can't bite through barrels at
least as far as i know
although yeah it wouldn't surprise me if
they could
but you know did you guys seriously i
don't even know if it's still there
but one of my favorite places to go when
i was a kid
growing up in florida was the alligator
farm
in saint augustine now they used to have
gomek who was the largest crocodile
in captivity now as you all know like
alligators are
native to florida crocodiles
native to the uh everglades now
as far as i know please correct me if
i'm wrong
but the everglades might be the only
place in the world where
alligators and crocodiles are both
native to the area
yes yeah i'm not sure if that's still
true or not
but for a long time that was true so but
they had bought
they had uh caught this particular
crocodile gomec
in new guinea i want to say
and he was at the alligator farm
in saint augustine but now
he's dead now um and he's stuffed there
but i went to the alligator farm when
that [ __ ] was still alive
and that was the most terrifying thing
that i have ever [ __ ] seen read what
riva t
said she's talking about [ __ ] she
says
well she says right there florida's [ __ ]
needs to go on a license plate
yes you speaking of gators did you see
the movie crawl we did we saw in the
theater
we saw in the theater actually yeah that
was a very florida movie also
yeah that totally seemed like something
that could legitimately happen
yeah because i laughed through most of
it i thought it was kind of corny but
it was but it was kind of fun corny
though yeah
i was just glad that i was on the
[ __ ] amc
[ __ ] um list for a list and i didn't
have to pay to see that movie
you know what i mean i mean like i said
it was fun it was just like a monster
movie it's like there's a monster movie
but had i paid
ten dollars to see that movie i probably
have been mad but
because you know i mean we could see
what three movies a week on a list i was
happy
although the whole that was funny the
whole time i was watching it i was
sitting there thinking to myself you
know
i have lived through a lot of hurricanes
in my time in florida
um i feel like that [ __ ] could pretty
easily happen
i mean we have a pond right down there
and then there's a bigger a way bigger
pond
right down there and um maybe alligators
in there probably yeah
me [ __ ] dressed up in my [ __ ]
jungle outfit [ __ ] going down there
and [ __ ] going into the water
catching some gators imagine what that
would do for the channel
you want to go wrestle alligators
wrestling are like a six foot alligator
okay well we need to go to
um that little swampy area yeah over
there
because where i haven't seen any gators
down to the other one i gotta check them
i gotta check
i've heard them yeah uh yeah not there
not where poopy goes and there's like a
bigger pond
they have a sign there it's like hey
don't swim in here maybe there's
alligators
i've never seen one i don't know if
there's any in there
but i've never seen one now the little
swampy area that
is how far is that from us is the crow
flies
about a half mile yeah it's not far like
it it seems far when you're walking on
the path because it's
roundabout y'all think i'm bullshitting
i'll jump in there and grab a gator
but now i'm not going to grab a [ __ ]
12-footer
but five six foot yeah maybe
i'd grab him well as long as you just
draw you're all right i know how to do
this job yeah i used to do that kind of
[ __ ] when i was a kid
yeah but they were much smaller but i'm
stronger now i go there and get him i'm
not worried about it
as long as they bite you they bite you
they can't do much to you i mean you
might just lose a hand who needs that
who needs that i've got another one but
um
yeah they're making it into something
that it isn't
did you see that picture remember that
picture that made the rounds a few years
ago
of the alligator with his mouth closed
that was like a human hand sticking out
and everyone thought it was fake it
wasn't though yeah that was like a dude
that was well he worked with them and
alligators cannot chew and no they
swallow everything
they swallow everything on a hole and
the kind of teeth that they have they
it's very difficult for them to bite
anything off they have to roll
and they don't really become dangerous
until they get to a certain size
um you know an alligator that weighs
about what i weigh or a little bit less
i'm not really worried about that i
take i take his ass you know what i mean
but when you're dealing with like a
[ __ ]
eight-foot alligator every foot you add
onto that alligator they exponentially
get harder and harder to deal with
you know a [ __ ] 12-foot alligator is
[ __ ] monstrous
it's not one guy's not gonna be able to
do that well and i have to tell you that
the ones that they had at the alligator
farm and um i realized this is a
crocodile which is a completely
different species
but the one that they the crocodile that
they had gomek at the um
at the alligator farm which as i said
the first time i saw me still alive like
when i went back later he died and
they'd stuffed him
but when you saw him alive it was
legitimately he was as big around
as how many people do i want to say
how big was how long was it he was
uh 18 feet 19 feet maybe 20.
that's [ __ ] huge um and it but it
wasn't that's about
it it wasn't the length that disturbed
me it was the
it was the width he was about at least
five people wide yeah if you were to
stack five people in the [ __ ]
he was he was just he was this like
[ __ ]
like they're strong they get tired quick
but they're strong
oh my god yeah i was like i just because
what they used to have they had him like
in an enclosure it was pretty big
and then you could go you could see him
from up top or you could go underneath
and there was like a tank and you could
see him from underneath the
you know with the through the window and
everything so you could kind of see him
and it's like i couldn't believe i was
just like sitting there looking at i
couldn't believe how [ __ ]
huge he was yeah it was just like the
big and it was like really really
upsetting like for some reason i'm
scared of sharks too
um so sharks are terrifying but for some
reason
alligators and crocodiles are like way
scarier to me i don't know why i don't
want to get eaten by a shark either but
i for real don't want to get eaten by an
alligator or a crocodile do you remember
that one that like [ __ ] ran across
the golf course
yeah that was a dinosaur oh my god it
was like a dragon
and that's the thing it's like you never
know
growing up like living in florida you
never know
when [ __ ] like that is just to wander
but because i you know i might have told
this story before but
there's also invasive species here like
pythons well yeah all the restrictors
are [ __ ] huge
i was driving from daytona to deland one
time
and on uh 92
and i'm driving and all of a sudden i
see this massive
alligator hauling ass
across six lanes of traffic
yeah and a median and i'm just like i'm
driving and i'm just like
what the [ __ ] am i looking at it was
like so [ __ ] surreal he was he was
booking it
and he was big and he was just like
running and he almost got hit like this
car was like
like on the other side and it was oh my
god it was like the [ __ ] craziest
[ __ ] i've ever seen now when i was a kid
um an alligator got run over by my
elementary school
it wasn't massive but it wasn't small
either
like somebody hit it with their car and
it had eventually killed it and like
some other people had run it over
so it's not an everyday sighting
but it's the kind of thing where if you
see it you're surprised
but you're not all that surprised you
know what i'm saying
so the fact that i was just seeing this
massive alligator
just hauling ass across six lanes of
highway while i was driving i was kind
of like
wow this is crazy but also tina's saying
is one deadlier than another i think
she's talking about crocodiles now
crocodiles are generally more aggressive
yeah there's been a lot of [ __ ]
people that have
kind of like there's been a lot of talk
you know
people will say look man a crocodile's
worse than an
alligator and other people will say well
now an alligator is probably worse than
a crocodile
if it doesn't live in your area then
it's worse than what you have a lot
that's the general rule the crocodile is
probably a little bit more aggressive
when it comes to [ __ ] grabbing
somebody
yeah all right but alligators i believe
get bigger
um or at least if you listen to the
rumors well crocodiles get bigger
crocodiles in general but it depends on
the rumors and the proof
well it depends on the species is what
it depends on because i've heard
i've heard rumors that there are
louisiana and florida alligators that
have gotten much bigger than crocodiles
could ever get which is true but i don't
well i don't know if it's just rumors or
not there's no saying it's different
there's rumors and proof i don't know
right of all the species that they've
collected
generally crocodiles are larger maybe
generally of the ones maybe collected
but there are several different
well the thing about it too is that
there's several different species of
crocodiles there's several different
cities
we have american alligators yeah there's
there's a weird there's a weird thing
there's a weird
dessert it's kind of like a weird
phenomenon if it's american then it's
not exotic
that's that's the phenomenon all right
if it's american then it can't be it
can't be uh
uh uh bigger or it can't be better or it
can't be stranger
there's no talent the florida evergreens
are [ __ ] huge
the the uh the you go down to new
orleans
there there there are [ __ ] swamps
down in new orleans
that [ __ ] probably no one's ever
[ __ ] actually step
set foot on there's all kinds of weird
[ __ ] out there that nobody knows about
you know like skunky skunk [ __ ]
dude is it raining yeah it's raining
it's difficult to say what the [ __ ]
um some people will defend the american
alligator the saying that the american
alligator is bigger than the crocodile
that it just is but like i said
they may not show them it depends on
what kind of crocodile you're talking
about there's
a bunch of different species of
crocodile um
and as i said if you go to the alligator
farm in uh
saint augustine which i've been to lots
of times i haven't been there in years
but they actually have they have all the
alligators there which like i said if
you go on a certain day you can
see them fed which is fascinating and
also terrifying
but they also have this whole walk
through and they have a whole bunch of
different species of crocodiles also
um so it's really interesting to see
like the different
because they have some that are kind of
like needle nosed and they have some
that are like this they have all
different kinds
there were animals in the early 1900s
that were reported and we don't have
proof of
but we well i'll tell you this
in new orleans in the early 1900s and
the 20s and the 30s they had paddle
boats
paddle boats they had big electric
contraptions on the front of them
and the whole job was to run around and
try to find alligator guard
electrocute them because they were
convinced that the alligator guard was a
threat to mankind
they were saying that somebody's
alligator gar and an alligator gar is a
fish it's a prehistoric fish yeah it's
not anything to do it's not around
nothing to do with an alligator it's a
fish but they were saying that these
things were 20 feet long
i believe that and that they were eating
i've seen some big ones back when i was
a kid
right and they were also saying that
there were alligator out there that were
22
23 24 25 feet long don't doubt it
monstrous alligators don't doubt it
but we're talking about the early 1900s
yeah okay
well you don't know how a long time ago
you don't
you don't know if they if they knew what
they were talking about or not
some people have said well
you talk about the early 1900s and
you're talking about animals that had
lived
longer than a hundred years old to get
that big
they're probably not living to
living long enough to get as big as they
could possibly get
i kind of feel like that might be i mean
and there's some proof of this
because there are european wood cuts
from the middle ages back you know on
the 1300s
1200s way back in the honky motherland
showing [ __ ] catfish next to a cow
and they're the same size as a cow
and people used to think that was a
[ __ ] lie
but that um that guy from [ __ ]
deadliest catches what was his name
[ __ ] uh we used to watch him
yeah [ __ ] jeremy ron jeremy what's it
not wrong
what's his name jeremy wade yeah
jeremy wade was proven that
things like catfish if allowed to live
long enough can get [ __ ] huge
because he caught some big [ __ ] huge
catfish okay well the medievals in
europe didn't have
[ __ ] block and tackle they didn't
have rod and reel so they weren't well
they didn't have industrial fishing yeah
so they weren't like
culling the population of the largest
members so some of these european lakes
had sea monsters in them which are
gigantic catfish that could swallow a
man
because eat honestly some of the catfish
that he caught
were huge were terrifying
so he's like okay this they can easily
fit a man's head and shoulders in their
mouth and he's like this catfish might
be 60 70 years old
how long do they live what happens if
you get a catfish that's 120 years old
how big is that
and then he would show those old wood
cuts because that looks like about right
yeah like that's totally that's about
doable yeah that's because some of these
animals can live
a snapping turtle they don't know how
long a snapping turtle could live
they get bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger i've seen snapping turtle
that big around in mississippi
and i don't think they were that big
maybe 30 years but how big are they at
120
well that's the thing about reptilians
is that we're not really sure
the thing about a lot of reptilians you
know alligators and stuff like that
is that they tend to just get bigger and
bigger and bigger yeah if they
um you know are not impeded in some way
if their environment isn't encroaching
on them in some way and if they have
enough to eat
then they'll just continue to grow and
they don't really
i'm not really sure like what their
outside lifespan is yeah nobody knows
how long an alligator lives
um victor says betty white is 99 and
she's not that
big nobody knows how long an alligator
lives
there's um
there's been records or or recorded
stories of guys buying alligators
that were in their 90s when they bought
them and they were huge
and then they keep these [ __ ] things
for [ __ ] decades
the guy dies in his [ __ ] 80s
and the alligator is found
dead in the [ __ ] in the habitat that
he made for it
but it died of starvation not old age
could be that an alligator might live to
be 120 130 years old well how big is
that
is that 24 feet you know
so we don't know i mean the thing about
it is that
if they grow to bigger than gomec was
because like i said i saw him when he
was alive and that was a crocodile
um then i'm about to piss my pants
because
that [ __ ] [ __ ] was
terrifying it's still scary to look at
now that because he's been stuffed and
posed and everything like they have a
really nice
display like with pictures of him when
he was alive and stuff
but i saw him when he was alive and
i can imagine like what the [ __ ] i was
thinking to myself the whole time i was
like safely
in the [ __ ] like looking at him through
the [ __ ] looking at this [ __ ]
giant belly that could fit like ten of
me
and i was just sitting there thinking
what if i was just
minding my own business swimming along
in
alexander springs or blue springs or
whatever like all the nice springs we
have here in central florida
what if i was just swimming along and
then i saw
that coming toward me i would [ __ ] my
pants
and then just probably die spontaneously
and then he would just eat me
because he was like a monster he was
like a monster
and i've never forgotten that like from
that day to this
like i said i went back later and i saw
him like after he had died and i saw him
when he was stuffed and it's still scary
but it
wasn't the same as seeing him when he
was like alive and moving around and
[ __ ]
when i was a kid i'm talking about 12
i went fishing in the bayou
in louisiana around an uncle
and he caught an alligator gar
that was probably about nine feet long
and i was [ __ ] astounded
that thing is [ __ ] huge and he was an
old man
he was in his 60s late 60s at the time
that he did that
that he caught it and he was like oh
that's a little one
when i was a kid they were twice this
big
and i thought he was bullshitting but
then as time went on no
he was probably telling the truth a lot
of this a lot of the american stuff that
we take for granted
back in the day of the early 1900s was a
lot bigger
because it was allowed to grow to a
larger size well yeah like i said you
didn't have industrial farming you
didn't
have a bunch of wine sure sure you
didn't have a bunch of people out there
fishing all the time you didn't have all
that
so and like you said jeremy
with [ __ ] yoda i was like god damn
the size of that thing
well they don't get as big as they used
to the thing about florida
you know mississippi all louisiana all
that kind of stuff is that
this environment this climate
fosters um
things to kind of get as big as they can
possibly get because the
you know the environment is just so lush
and fertile
that which in a way is bad because
we have a lot of uh invasive species
like
seriously like some rich dude like
imports hey i'm gonna have all these
exotic animals or whatever
and then he dies and they all escape or
whatever happens
and then they all escape into the wild
and they're like hey i kind of like this
environment i'm just going to
deal with this and then they take over
like the whole local ecosystem
because it's so it's hot here
it's wet it's like there's
plentiful uh you know
you know kind of uh foliage there's
plentiful
other little animals you can feed on
there's
just all kind of wildlife so it's like
anything that you let loose in florida
will probably just [ __ ] take over
yeah because that's just kind of the
environment that we live in it's like
it's just swampy
like it's like dagobah yeah um
if that sounds like something you'd like
then sure move to florida but i'm just
i'm
warning you if you don't like
feeling like wet all the time
like your butt crack is just damp and
you can't like you seriously you take a
shower
and you dry off but you don't dry off
because you just you're still sweaty it
if you want to feel like that
then move like all the time then move to
florida because that's kind of what it
feels like all the time
there was an airplane pilot that was
flying over somewhere in new orleans or
in in the
orlando new orleans in the uh
tila says first time i saw an armadillo
was in florida i see armadillos all the
time most of them are dead i have to
admit they get hit by cars
but i do see live ones um while i'm
walking like there's a lot of them along
the path i see them like snuffling
around
yeah they're blind and they don't they
can't smell too well
and they love deer's buttholes yeah i
love deers buttholes
there were some programmers watching
where a uh a pilot was flying over
but some kind of bayou in louisiana
and was it an alligator that he saw you
were watching with me was it an
alligator or was it an alligator gar
i thought it was a snake but i could no
i think it was an alligator
okay i'm maybe i'm remembered there's an
alligator and by his estimation it was
well over 20 feet long
which like that does not surprise me at
all yeah and
he tried he took a picture of he went
back later and took a picture of where
it was
and then drew out how big it looked it
was well over 20 feet
and um they were trying to find that
alligator
remember that yeah i vaguely remember i
think it was an alligator
i mean because the thing is like the
trail that i walk on the seminole chiva
trail
like a little like a little over a mile
up the road
there's a little scenic overlook and
there's like a little swamp area
now i have never seen an alligator in
there
however i have heard them multiple times
because the mama alligators make that
weird sound
to their babies like a grunting sound
yeah that weird like
what kind of noise like and sometimes
when you walk by there like you can hear
their little
sound that they make so you know that
they're in there
but i've never actually seen one you
know what's weird
okay so the other morning because i walk
this trail like
every day so the other morning i'm up
there
there's there's an overlook there's the
swamp and then
what's up kyle what's up bro over here
there's like a little um thing there's
like a little bike rack
so you can park your bike there and
there's little little benches and a
trash can or whatever
so i'm walking by there and right by the
bike rack
there was a pair of almost
new like wading boots like rubber boots
and they almost looked like kid or
teenage kid
size yeah and they were just left there
by the bike rack and there was nobody
around
and then and i'm just like i'm like
looking at him and i'm like
i wonder what happened to the person
that owned those [ __ ] boots
i'm like did they take those boots off
and then an alligator came up and ate
them or
did they fall in the swamp and then they
drowned or like i couldn't figure it out
and i just kept like i walked past there
a couple days and like those boots were
there and it was just like mystifying
and i was like
whose are those it's like why are those
there and then like a couple days later
i walked past and they were gone
so i don't know if somebody just took
them or
if somebody ate that person or i don't
really know it was just like it was just
really real
it was weird because the the boots were
they were small enough that they could
have been like a kid or maybe a woman
you know what i mean yeah and they
didn't look old or worn out
oh my god damn they didn't look brand
new either they look like they've been
used like maybe a time or two
but it looked like someone had took them
off deliberately like by the bike rack
but there was no bike there there was no
nothing and it's like
so like then the whole time like you
know i you know i'm a horror writer so i
was like sitting there like thinking up
all these scenarios in my brain as to
what had happened to this person
and i still don't [ __ ] know trying to
turn the volume up and see the
sounds getting kind of low oh okay well
it's all the way up
it is all the way up it's all the way up
bro the mic is all the way up yeah yeah
but yeah so i i still don't know what
happened to those boots or that person
and that was like right across from from
the pot woods
where those people live there's these
people they live like there
there's the overlook and then right
across from that there's a little bit of
woods and then there's a house
and the house has like a whole bunch of
um like
some outbuildings and they sell firewood
and show like that
and i'm pretty sure allegedly
that they sell pot because or that they
grow pot in the woods because every now
and then
when i walk past that area it's like
really really pungently weed smelly not
every day it's just maybe once a month
and i'm like are they like trying out
their new batch or
what's the deal like because there's
nothing back there in the woods as far
as i know
there's a little bit of a path but
there's a house and he's got like a
you know a little boat and he's got like
some a couple out buildings like little
garages and [ __ ]
i don't know i feel like they're
probably growing pop back there but like
i said i'm not going to [ __ ] nark on
them because why would i
but you know i'm just saying so i don't
know who
those [ __ ] boots were the weird thing
too is that the other day
and i just now that i'm thinking about
it i only just remember this
i was out there the other day i don't
think this was the same day i saw the
boots
but when i was walking back toward that
area
i saw something run across the trail
now there was two of them there was one
and it ran across into the woods and
then another one ran across into the
woods
too small to be a deer i've seen deer
run across there even like little fawns
and [ __ ] like that i've seen that
it was too small to be that um
not a cat it wasn't moving like a cat it
wasn't an
otter because i've seen otters run
across there too weirdly enough
um and it wasn't a dog so i'm not real
sure
i don't know like i got up there and i
feel like somebody like there was a dude
like walking
up the opposite way and i think he saw
it too because he kept like looking in
the woods and i'm just like what the
[ __ ] was that and he's like i don't know
i saw something
like run across there and i couldn't
figure out what it was i mean is this
florida it could be [ __ ]
it could be literally anything seriously
um
and like i said i've seen otters lots of
times
so which is weird because there's like
water over there and they go into the
woods and do
whatever otters do when they go in the
woods i don't know i don't know if
there's other water over there i don't
think so
but so they run across every now and
then they go back to the water so i've
seen that
um and like i said it wasn't a cat it
wasn't a dog it wasn't a deer i don't
know what it was
it wasn't a raccoon or a possum
oh she came back in do you want granola
bar no okay
but i'll save it for tomorrow all right
i wouldn't mind another drink though
okay here i was just talking about all
the various
wildlife that i see out on the [ __ ]
trail
he doesn't care he doesn't care
brittany says we get a lot of snapping
turtles i see him every now and then i
haven't seen one a long time
we get a lot of those um just the little
slow tortoises i see them in the
like the grass on the side of the trail
sometimes
i did see a raccoon the other day though
like i know because you said
uh straw dog said it was probably a
raccoon it wasn't a raccoon though
because we see raccoons all the time
um and it wasn't moving like a raccoon
it didn't have a tail like a raccoon it
wasn't the same size as a raccoon
i saw a raccoon the other day that i
think
i think might have been a juvenile
because it was its body was
about this about the size of an adult
but the tail wasn't all like fully
fluffed out yet
so i feel like it was maybe a teenager
and plus it's fur was a was
not it didn't have thank you didn't have
like all the
the adult coloring you know what i mean
and [ __ ] man we've got
raccoons what did we say that like
pookie we found pookie the other night
sitting next to a raccoon under a tree
in the backyard
just sitting there just showing me look
look it's my friend
yeah that's my friend funny and beijing
loves raccoons like whenever some
raccoons like you know
kind of traipse along into our backyard
if beijing is outside she is kind of
like
she goes up to him like oh let me join
your family i also have a fluffy tail
i think it's because they all have
fluffy tails i think she feels like an
affinity
i'm not really sure why it's really
weird to me how not
even though it's a different species and
you would think that they would smell
weird
or something like that but there doesn't
seem to be like animosity
between the two species which is very
strange no cat cats and um
raccoons love each other which that's
very that's so weird
yeah because like every now and then
like we'll get a possum too every now
and then
like because remember when we last time
we grilled and then
i guess like possum everywhere like
smelled the [ __ ] meat or smelled
whatever and they came
and like were like ooh and they were
trying to like climb around the grill or
whatever and then pookie was like
alarming us it's like
hey there's an ugly cat out here it's
like what the [ __ ] is this it stinks
and we then we came out we saw the
possum so they're not
super into possum now i had an old cat
when i was
younger that actually got into a fight
with a possum
and the possum tore her
the top of her lip off like right here
like they got into a fight and the
possum like bit her mouth
and it tore like a part of her lip off
so
um so cats and possums seem to be like
not so
friendly but cats and raccoons that
seems to be a different
uh issue and that is very strange to me
but i've seen a lot of videos where
with cats and ravens cats and owls
cats and a lot of i mean i don't know i
think people have like a misconception
that cats are just oh they're predators
so they just like hate everybody
and they just want to kill everybody but
that's i don't think that's the case
sophie says she thinks cats and skunks
like each other too
it's just there's all kinds of weird
[ __ ] happening in the animal kingdom
that's just it's very very funny to me
like like inner species
friendships are fascinating to me
well they're not competitors evidently i
guess that must be what it is so maybe
they're just more interested
in each other than anything else but
what's funny is that
a cat will reject another cat it'll hiss
at it well yeah they're like oh
that's kind of like a [ __ ] raccoon
and go oh wow you know
look how pretty wow he has little human
hands right yeah
because like i said there used to be
where i used to work had um
it was a newspaper and there was a
massive parking lot and i used to work
the night shift and there was a little
family of raccoons that lived
in the parking lot and everybody knew
about it so every now and then like if
you had leftover food you would go out
there on your break
and you would you know take pizza crusts
or whatever you had
hey pookie and you would take pizza
crust or whatever like outside
and then you would see like sometimes
the raccoon family would come to your
car
like when you were leaving at night or
sometimes they would come up to the door
and they were like the mom was so cute
because she would just come up and she'd
be on her back legs and with her little
hands out
hey what you got because she was so used
to like people giving her stuff
for her babies khan's rebooting his
phone
how long we've been uh streaming for 239
2039
kayla says there are actually people who
are extremely afraid of cats
it's weird i do not understand that at
all yeah
i don't understand people who are afraid
of cats i don't understand people who do
not like cats
i don't understand and you know yeah i
know there's dog people in cat people
um you know but
i don't know i like dogs too but
people i don't know like people feel
like cats aren't
like they don't oh they don't have the
same personality as dogs or they're not
as you know friendly or they're not as
whatever it i think it depends on what
kind of what cat you get
let's do it it's just like a person
zack says my mom hates cats because
she's allergic and she thinks they're
dirty
yeah that's the craziest thing i've ever
heard what are you looking at but cats
aren't dirty
actually if you you could pick up pookie
right now and smell her
she smells like baby powder yeah she
always smells like baby powder
you smell like baby powder every now and
then if she's been running around
outside she'll smell a little bit sweaty
but still not bad
but she pretty much always smells like
baby powder yeah beijing does too
they smell like baby powder to me i
think it's the um
i think it's the litter box that people
don't like the smell of
which okay you know i know that there
are whole channels dedicated to cats but
we can't have a whole [ __ ] stream did
it what
why not it doesn't work out that way
besides we're losing
we're losing [ __ ] people watching the
show all right
is it now at this time this would be a
good time to ask you people
is there anything that you wanted to
talk about is there any kind of subjects
you want us to get on before we go ahead
and check
off sorry because we've been on for like
over two we've been on for nearly two
hours so
sorry everybody's talking about cats
they're all talking about cats now
sophie said
i was wary of cats before my big guy
found me and changed my mind
see that's another thing that i've heard
before i knew
someone who was the dad of a friend of
mine
and he said the same thing he's like you
know i always hated cats i thought they
were like really aloof and it's like
they didn't really have any time for us
and they were [ __ ] and [ __ ] like
that
they just like and then we got one it's
like it wasn't my decision
you know it was my wife or my girlfriend
or whatever he's like and then i got one
he's like and then i got it
because it's like that cat was like he
was like my best butt
and i feel like if you don't like cats i
just feel like you haven't had the right
cat
because they're just like everything
else they just they have a personality
just like everyone else does
i mean pookie and beijing have very
very different personalities beijing is
beijing is a little bit aloof but
she's more like the princess type where
she's kind of like
all right i've i will deign to let you
pay attention to me for a moment
because i am so beautiful like she is a
little bit like that
um but she's also kind of goofball like
she has like kind of a
she has a little bit of a prankster side
every now and then
you see it like she'll you'll come
through the kitchen and she'll decide
she's gonna hide behind the wall and
then jump up the wall into your face and
be like hi i got you you know what i
mean
so she does that every now and then but
it's just it's very rare but she does do
it sometimes
pookie on the other hand is more like
it's kind of hard to describe she's kind
of like a little
court jester you know what i mean she
always she always wants to follow you
she always wants to like know what
you're doing she's like hey would you
can i get involved can i help you can i
[ __ ] it up in some way
and so it's like she always wants to be
involved in what you're doing
and she's like really
interactive like she always wants to
like look at your face she always what
she's like always wants to talk to you
she's always looking directly at you
she's always trying to like get a rise
out of you
and she knows that if she does certain
things
then it will get you to pay attention to
her so
she will she's learned very well like
how to do those things so she'll kind of
like
oh my goodness did you jump over the
tree you all right
she's so noisy you know like you know
like last night
she wanted to go outside again even
though she had been outside and it was
too late
so we let her come in we turned all the
lights off we took her little collar off
or whatever
and then she kept she kept like looking
out the window she kept looking
back at tom looking out the window
looking back at times she's like man
me and he's like no you can't go outside
she's like
like so she talks like that and then
like if you don't pay attention to her
she like trundles over to the nightstand
and she pops up her little head pops up
on the side
and then she looks like what can i knock
off pow and then she like knocks
something off and then she's like
and then she backs off and she like
makes a little four little four-legged
stance like looking at you like yeah
bring it what are you gonna do
you gonna do something you know what i
mean so she does that kind of [ __ ]
so um and i think i mentioned it before
too but
she talks to herself in the mirror which
is very very weird to me because i've
never had a cat that did that before
but yeah she jumps up on the bathroom
counter
looks in the mirror very deliberately
and goes
talks to herself and then turns and
looks at us so i think she knows how a
mirror works and
what that does what'd she do just run
around she wanted to go out she wanted
to go out but then she saw it was still
raining she's like i [ __ ] all that
she's like no i'm going to get it i'm
going to get wet and stinky yeah it was
like that's really weird that kind of
came out of nowhere didn't it
i just kind of heard it and then i was
kind of like oh she'll probably want to
come back in
but then she'll blame us because she
thinks that's our fault that that's
happening
yeah right sophie says i still think i'm
a hardcore
dog person who happens to have cats as
children and now appreciates them
that makes me happy to hear i like dogs
too like i said
but i guess i always had cats growing up
i had one dog when i was a kid and i
hated it
because i thought it was stupid and i
didn't like
the thing i didn't like about dogs when
i was a kid was that one they were
always loud
they're always barking two they're
always jumping on you and drooling and
they were super
needy i don't know like there was
something that i didn't like about
well they're real social you know
they're right i think that's kind of why
i liked cats better because even though
they can come off as kind of aloof to
some people and like i said it depends
on the
on what cat you get because they all
have their own little personalities
because pookie is not aloof at all
see
[Laughter]
she just wants to be involved in
whatever that's a dog-like cat though
she's very puppy-like yeah but in a way
that like she'll go off and sleep and
she'll do her own thing
but she does kind of want to be she's
like hey what you doing what you know
what you know
she does kind of do that but i that was
one thing i didn't like about dogs is
they feel like they felt like
children in a way that they were always
like up in your
grill all the time you know what i'm
saying yeah which
i was like man if i wanted kids i would
just have kids
you know what i mean i don't need that
[Laughter]
yeah right you seem like you're kind of
like yeah i'm done i'm done
i'm done tonight i'm [ __ ] i've been
we've been on the on the uh
show for about two hours two hours and
47 minutes yeah i'm gonna go ahead and
check out if you want to continue to do
the show you go ahead and do it
all right well okay bye bye
[Laughter]
are you going to take your movie or take
the movie okay
i'll see you around you guys
all right well i guess i gotta go
because well you know whatever
no he's being a douche all right so
uh i will see you guys on saturday
because he's obviously worn out he's
sick you know um so i'm just gonna
pretend whatever um
yeah so again
uh we'll have what do we have we have
witching hour tomorrow we have a movie
review on friday and then we'll be back
on saturday doing a live stream
hopefully tom will feel better by then
but thank you guys for dropping by
tonight on this
again drunken live stream i can't
believe how much it's raining this is
unbelievable
and uh we'll see you guys on saturday
and thank you all for dropping by again
bye